amy lui samedi soir on va essayer une
autre
chers amis chers ennemis préférés quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
ouais
chers amis chers ennemis bienvenue sur
le plateau de tout le monde en parle
l'émission ou avec nous ce soir
bernard tapie pascale roberts
agnès soral
natacha amal
mathilde de pédant
léonie janot
la kouchner
olivia adriaco
il était wyss
christophe alévêque
l'auteur de je suis noir mais je n'aime
pas le manioc la star des invasions
barbares tranche chicago
le premier bond
25 ans près julie depardieu yann moix
la neige de monsieur philippe corti
laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
non sans l'euro
m
merci bonsoir leur nom soit retiré
on me demande souvent des nouvelles de
michaël blanc qui entame sa cinquième
année de détention
alors aujourd'hui tout battage
médiatique est inutile je crois qu'il
vaut mieux compter sur l'action discrète
mais je l'espère efficace du ministre
des affaires étrangères dominique de
villepin en attendant ici on souhaite
tous à michaël blanc d'en revenir le
plus vite possible
et puis un peu un peu de suivi sur les
bonnes actions
victoria abril nous avait parlé de
orphanage africa c'est vrai donc moi
j'ai promis que je m'inscrirai je les
fais beaucoup de gens ont fait pas mal
de problèmes mais ayew avait dit qu'elle
devrait un chèque à clowns sans
frontières
je crois que clowns sans frontières
attend toujours ton gros chez cos
on a peut-être été en vacances n'a pas
zappé peut-être le chèque est sur la
table de nuit mais envoie le voilà
marty
merci bernard tapie pascale robert
alliès
asham a
bonsoir à tous
énorme ovation dans la vie
ces comédiennes faut dire que c'est un
petit peu comme ça où tu es à tous les
soirs donc ça me change cela beaucoup
alors vous arrivez du théâtre donc du
théâtre de paris rue blanche où vous
interpréter un beau [__] pour 100
représentations exceptionnelles depuis
le 30 janvier
alors c'est bourré c'est tous les soirs
bohai les gens se marrent ça va durer
plus de 100 représentations ben
apparemment on est parti pour cent
maintenant il est probable que si toutes
les conditions sont réunies pour que on
continue et que tout le monde peut
puisse le faire on sera on verra ce
normalement représentations
exceptionnelles c'est du pipeau ça
commence pour appâter les gens mais en
fin de compte vous êtes vous allez jouer
ça brasse à 100 fois alors c'est une
pièce de pierre chesnot mise en scène
par jean luc moreau ou l' inverse mais
bon non c'est il ya d'ailleurs été déjà
joué par jean luc moreau en acteur
principal à la place de bernard tapie
avec des textes additifs de bernard
tapie
vous avez rajouté des petits trucs aucun
auteur n'aurait noeud rose et dire en
fait comme je suis un beau [__] on a
ajouté aux qualités de ce beau [__]
les miennes mais en tout cas présumés
tels ce qui fait qu évidemment je
deviens un sérieux les drire ya un truc
génial c'est quand il arrive sur scène
donc il dit vous savez moi vous me
connaissez je déteste le mensonge et la
drève nombreuses salles et les paieries
d'ailleurs explosé de rien je sais pas
pourquoi il ya beaucoup d'autodérision
et vous avez donc enrichi le personnage
du départ qui en fait à un coureur un
cours classique ou un menteur mais là où
j'en ai fait un personnage plus plus
épais le bernard tapie telle qu'on que
les médias nous l'ont raconté pendant
des années non mais je crois qu'il est
il et il est de toute façon il est de
toute façon cynique et dans cet exercice
là il est de toute façon menteur et ce
qui est intéressant c'est que parmi les
1000 spectateurs qui appuient ce que ça
contient à peu près on se sent il y en a
forcément qui sont beaucoup plus menteur
que moi sur ce sujet là puisque trompent
leur femme pas moi donc c'est ça
vous aimez commence très fort depuis
trente deux ans tiens à dire que bernard
tapie est avec son épouse depuis 32 ans
et qui l'a jamais trompé jamais en
france bernard je crois qu'on a un à ma
mère je te crois pas capable
oui c'est ça une espèce de sale au
dragueur tchatcheur mais en fait qu'ils
se trouvent toujours une bonne excuse un
bon prétexte en la viande hachée com -
m6 a toujours raison si vous êtes vous
demandé aux femmes
chaque fois que le mec trompe sa femme
il commence par expliquer pendant des
heures pourquoi il le fait un évidement
c'est à cause d'elle elle ne comprend
pas il est malheureux el bez mal enfin
il a toujours 1000 1500 bonnes raisons
pour expliquer à la maîtresse qui est
pas dupe
voilà pourquoi je trompe pas sinon je
l'aurais jamais trompé et bien entendu
voilà c'est ça l'histoire
en tous les cas vous fait le clown et
vous avez l'air d'aimer ça les gens
adorent ça donc tout va bien
oui mais je reviens en enfance c'est ça
la fin la vertu de l'acteur c'est d'être
en enfance je vous donne un exemple
pendant les répétitions n'a pas nos
objets d'art à l'aider et on sent à
vente
alors si l'objet choisi pour être un
revolver c'est un cendrier ouais et bien
le troisième jour quand on commence à
répéter où il est mon revolver il s'agit
de retrouver le cendrier qu'il devient
de revolver et si j'avais la paille
n'est pas question de changer par autre
chose
donc cette espèce de facultés de
redevenir enfant et de jouer que mon
jouet quand on est gosse complète
chauffeurs d'autocars fait semblant
nettement avec on se relève comme et
c'est ça ma fille joue au docteur lui
bat hip hop c'est pareil ici tu te
souviens tu as joué docteur z et
terminait-il jouer connaît la
température je fais partie de mettre 500
diplômés du canon mais à la fin de la
pièce quand je dis vous prenez du
plaisir mais bon on dirait de funès que
vous souhaitez vous fait des grimaces
vous tournez sur vous même
c'est insensé écoutez c'est vraiment
venu au fur et à mesure que la pièce le
suscitait cas de nature on a tous eu
dose de pudeur qui vous empêche de faire
passer ces choses j'ai quand même pas
courir avec la valise à la main
en fait maintenant je saute au dessus
des tâches et du très beau sur damien
parce que c'est vrai truc rêver les
enfants
alors voilà donc ce beau [__] change
de femme tous les dix ans donc il ya
quatre femmes autour de lui à vous
d'abord pascal robert ce qui avait été
sa première femme inconditionnels allen
l'adorent un testament c'est sa maman sa
maman enfin bon mais en fait moi je
connais l'âge de pascale roberts et
franchement vous êtes super en forme a
vraiment voilà donc vous vous êtes la
première femme c'est vrai depuis 20 ans
et avec vous chers agnès soral un
vuvuzela épouse l'épousé official la
femme
moi je suis un voile à l'officiel
l'officiel natacha vii la maîtresse
dépressive et alcoolique extraordinaire
très bien gaulée je dois dire parce
qu'il faut dire dans cette pièce est que
quand même un des grands plaisirs de la
pièce
et puis rejoue un poil l effet des
études
avec une nuisette pas traînant dans tout
le monde fait ça pour voir votre culotte
je me savais quand même la chance parce
qu'elle n'en met pas alors une amende
n'arrive pas à la voir
qui montrent un fou rire voilà natacha
vous êtes la maîtresse depuis dix ans 1
et puis voilà et puis le beausset à
l'eau bernard tapie vous quitte pour
vous mathilde penin dont vous êtes la
petite découverte apic nouvelles comme
ça sur laquelle il est très très chaud
mais quand on vous voit en comprend et
il est prêt à partir avec elle donc ce
que je disais c'est quand la pièce
commence le beau [__] s'apprête à tout
plaquer les trois femmes qui sont là
pour vous pour partir en australie avec
vous le problème c'est que c'est son
anniversaire il a 55 ans ouais voilà
sept jours et essaie bien choisis je
dois ziralo ouais c'est pato en fait le
vrai truc c'est que je dois me tirer en
douce et mais il ya chez moi ma valise
avec tous mes pape la voilà et donc je
dis à ma fiancée julie écoute tu m'as
temps on se retrouve à l'aéroport je
vais chercher la valise est évidemment
je donne un coup de fil à ma femme pour
lui dire d'aller se coucher je peux pas
rentrer et elle m'apprend que c'est
l'anniversaire qui a une grande fête
voilà donc voilà le problème c'est guy
forget arrive à tirer la valise au
moment où il ya une fête géante
voila voila est donc évidemment problème
alors là oui c'est malin en plus c'est
que chaque génération de femmes dans la
salle se retrouve dans une de vos quatre
c'est là aussi sur le plan marketing cds
thouars mais parce que évidemment tout
le monde se reconnaît les hommes se
reconnaissent dans le personnage du du
beau [__] saut vous en faites pas ce
que vous finalement comme on l'a dit ça
fait 32 ans que vous êtes avec votre
épouse et vous ne l'avez jamais trompé
alors cci du havre marche elle
ah mais c'est normal dans un couple y
aura toujours pour que ça dure faut
qu'ils en aient un key s'aérer elle
alors c'est dû à quoi c'est dû au fait
que c'est très sexuel ternat c'est en
tout cas ça peut pas être ça veut pas
être l'élément qui m'aurait fait partir
moi non mais je crois qu'il ya d'abord
une volonté que ça dure parce que chaque
couple a des moments de crise forcément
et et ces moments de crise où on est
surmontée l'ironie bon allez on essaie
quand même ou bien et c'est tout à fait
légitime dans certains cas de guillaume
on laisse aller et on dit autre chose
ensuite il ya les activités
professionnelles qui joue un rôle si on
a 80 % de son temps actif
résolument tourné sur son 1/4 sur son
travail sur ce que l'on fait
reconnaissez qu'on a moins de temps n'y
a pas besoin de ça vous dit si j'avais
pas tendre ces gens là peut-être trompé
si jamais rien eu à [__] de hernie
j'ai eu dix heures par jour à rien faire
mais je l'aurais fait ensuite il ya
aussi quelle est l'évolution dans le
temps des deux personnages
il ya des gens qui évolue d'une manière
ou d'une autre mais en tout cas rarement
de la même manière et là je crois qu'on
a eu à peu près la chance d'évoluer
parts égales maintenant bernard à l'âge
que vous avez ya plus tellement de
réserve ou latronquière la même plus
aucune est ce que vous croyez que les
femmes ont plus à gagner en étant
féminine que féministe 6 2 c'est à moi
je dis féminine féminine crois qu'on a
posé la question à bernard
alors moi je répondrai
non franchement je répondrais sa départ
ça dépend de l'heure de la journée
alors la pièce s'appelle un beau [__]
vous vous trouvez beau parce que ça ne
s'est fait pas les [__] c'est admis
ebuya le maquillage
ouais le soir il ya un gros j'avais pas
mal bernard sérieux c'est vrai je vais
pas un cheveu blanc non non il est bien
à munich cheveux si abbaoui je vais pas
bah sinon ils s'assoient patrouilles et
des mecs chez qui ce sera énorme
non parce qu'il y en a trop ou pas rire
cela il ya un moment quand c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai là c'est le moment le
plus dur c'est ni blanc ni gris ouais
alors ça c'est un peu dégueulasse
moi ce que j'aime bien
oui ça lui va bien parce que tout lui va
on n'a pas ces chantiers mais qui
parlait de chauves avant d'être blanc
oui mais ça ne te barres pas parce que
bondy 3 les filles qu'est ce qu'il a de
plus séduisant lui bernard tapie moi je
dirais son naturel
ah ouais moi j'aime ça y est il est
direct nature sa pêche le fait qu'ils se
laissent pas démonter
c'est plutôt une espèce de fragilité qui
se voit à certains qu'ils décèlent à
certains moments et et/ou vraiment je
trouve qu'il a l'air d'un enfant je
dirais qu'il ya une virilité évident une
viralité des vies normales as tu veux
c'est réglé à la vue de prêtres
et avec la vitesse que sa femme est
restée dans les annales
peut-être toutes les qualités réunies
je pense que c'est une
une femme qui doit être à ses multiples
oui elle a encore dit en anglais oui
sûrement on le retenir wijaya l'intrus
dacquois salaires une gamine
l unité elle est très jolie jolie elle
doit être très intelligent qu'on se tape
pas non plus ce qu'elle sait faire c'est
elle sait faire que vous la laisse aller
mais voilà quoi tout est sous contrôle
ouais c'est ça le tient par les couilles
j'ai l'impression aussi vous pensiez
quoi pascal de lui avant de le connaître
moi il m'a toujours fasciné par cette
espèce de sympathie qu'il peut qu'il
dégage et même je le trouvais fariza me
dit quelque chose on n'y croit pas ça je
trouve ça formidable
c'est le problème alors pensez quoi
je l'avais rencontrée sur le lellouche
ah oui et j'avais donc je connaissais
d'avant et je l'avais vu genou bon il
faisait rêver à l'époque je sais pas à
la manière dont il a été porté comme ça
au sommet je me disais c'est bien ça
fait rêver
xavier un bon a priori avons rencontré
oui vous aussi notre chat excellent
parce que j'avais gardé de lui
certaines images des missions non dans
lesquelles il avait brillé dans par le
passé comme par exemple le débat le pen
avec le pen alors ça c'était quelque
chose qui m'avait vraiment marqué
va-t-il vous pensez quoi de tapis avant
de le rencontrer
je pensais que c'était quelqu'un qui
savait tout faire c'est ce qu'on a comme
image et pour l'instant c'est ce que je
pense toujours des coptes comme comédien
il a des progrès à faire comme comédien
vous trouvez c'est un froid est en train
de se faire flasher sur le tout à
l'heure tout à l'heure on était dans la
loge
agnès m'a donné une indication viande
l'instant à ce moment là fait plutôt ça
je vais le faire non mais c'est vrai
parce que on ne voit pas mais ce qu'on
entend c'est la réaction des gens et là
on voit bien mois y avait un truc que je
voulais pas faire là vous donner mais il
y avait un moment où je servais un
alcool à une psychanalyste est las
qu'elle raconte pas le coup non ma
parole mais je dis simplement ce moment
là ils me faisaient pas marrer et
j'étais gêné de le faire sous mais sa
maman j'ai à chaque fois zh rien j'étais
jamais faire ça moi j'étais j'aime faire
ça je me régale maintenant si vous
l'avez vu ses amours il en fait un
maximum mais c'est drôle et c'est à
mourir et les gens le réclament mais ça
donne ça donne pas envie d'y aller pas
de rigoler et a peur d'être heureux ma
fille
donner du bonheur pendant des mois est
mort al banani privé
quand tu sors en soirée tu emmènes ton
public qui applaudit à chaque vague pas
moi ça des experts
je vous demande de vous arrêter
rien d'inquiétant
finalement cette pièce était fait pour
vous parce que j'ai retrouvé une
déclaration de vous 113 99 g sol une
déclaration de vous lors du procès om
valenciennes et vous avez déclaré j'ai
menti mais c'était de bonne foi ouais
ben là c'est ça dans la pièce
si vous me demandez leur et je vous dis
il est 16h cibafi vous demande l'heure
et que vous lui dites 16 heures alors qu
il était 17 heures vous avez menti de
bonne foi c'est ça mentir de bonne
famille est à dire vous dit quelque
chose qui est une erreur ou est une
fausse information vous l'a dit de bonne
foi alors que la dent dans ce qu'on joue
je suis de mauvaise foi et jeudi une
information fausse en sachant qu'elle
est fausse mais voilà les voilà c'est du
théâtre
c'est plus la résistance et voila voila
c'est la communiste qui souhaite c'est
très chouette alors on veut bien croire
un coupé au montage
on veut on veut bien croire que vous
ayez jamais menti à votre à votre femme
mais vous avez menti à d'autres gens
dans votre vie quelle est la plus belle
promesse que vous ayez faite par exemple
à vos parents sans l'avoir tenue
je n'ai pas menti avait pas ouais c'est
pas par vertu c'est parce que ça s'est
pas présenté et j'avais réel vous n'avez
pas eu l'occasion quoi voilà c'est
maintenant oui alors vers des gens c'est
bien quand je parle à des chants j'ai
l'impression d'être le seul moteur du
monde
sous-entendu vous montez pas moi
personnellement ça ce sera coupée au
montage
bernard ça veut dire mentir d'un arc et
la plus belle promesse que vous ayez
faite aux français quand vous étiez
ministre sans l'avoir tenue
je vais vous dire d'abord celle que j'ai
fait est que j'ai tenus parce que celle
là on en a jamais tenu rigueur et je
suis content que natacha et tettey est
été marqué par ce débat j'avais dit à
cette occasion là quand je suis rentré
en politique je mettrai le pen à moins
de 10% est la seule élection nationale à
laquelle j'ai participé c'était les
élections européennes où le pen a fait
9,8
ouais et moi j'ai fait très 14-13 de
calais donc je suis content d'avoir tenu
cet engagement là et celui-là il valait
quelque chose qui tient les engagements
merci cartes de mon client
alors les engagements les engagements
que je n'ai pas tenus c'est tout ce que
j'ai promis ont d'autres ministres ouais
pour une raison simple c'est que le
temps de réaction de ce que l'on dit par
rapport à l'action ce mois par an
j'étais ministre un an
ouais donc voilà donc voilà là il n'y a
rien de tenues retenue alors les
promesses que vous avez pas tenu
vis-à-vis de vos employés
aucune parce que les employés devenaient
les employés définitif que lorsque le
ménage avait malheureusement été fait
ouais tu te demande la carte mais non
mais attends vous êtes vous découvrez
aujourd'hui les les horreurs des
licenciements sous-entendu il ya des
gens qui quand il se trouve dans une
structure qui marchent pas peuvent
licencier au nom de l'impératif besoin
de sauver l'entreprise et y en a
d'autres pour qui sait des bouchers
charcutiers chaque fois qu'ils
licencient à quelqu'un c'était presque
un bonheur et un plaisir de le faire
alors moi je sais pas faire je vous
donner deux exemples concrets voyage fut
pas cette question
quand je reprends adidas adidas perd à
peu près deux milliards par an le
concurrent principal c'est nike qui
gagne 2 milliards par an pourquoi ils
sont plus intelligents ils sont vos
goûts nike travail avec 7000 employés
tous des enfants chinois ou taïwanais
tous nous ont travaillé douze mille
employés tous se repère points c'est
plus lent
deux hypothèses vous laisser comme ça et
adidas est mort c'est possible ou vous
avez la charge de l'arbre et c est vous
laverez c'est en faisant ce qui a été
fait à dire des fermetures d'usinés
qu'on coûte
et quatre ou cinq mille emplois sur 12
mais il faut comprendre moi que les 4000
qu ont perdu leur boulot sur les 12000 à
cause de moi considère que je suis le
roi des [__] parce que quand vous
leur expliquer que c'est pour sauver
l'entreprise ils s'en foutent ils ont
perdu leur boulot
pour certains il on retrouve pas avant
trois quatre ans mais c'est comme ça je
veux dire que c'est un métier qui est
hors keith haring j'aurais préféré
rester toute ma vie d'artiste bas mais
malheureusement j'ai pas eu j'ai pas eu
l'intelligence de dire oui à lelouch
compterait 25 ans c'est vrai je vous
assure vraiment je regrette d'aldo
maccione à l'époque oui
non mais c'est dans l'aventuré que je
regrette parce que je trouve dans ce
métier tout ce que j'aime
il n'y a rien de ce que je n'aime pas
donc vous regretté de pas avoir commencé
plutôt être comédien ah oui vraiment
j'aurais pas affronter toutes ces merdes
bien alors qu'elle est la promesse que
vous aviez fait un juge et vous avez pas
tenu ils n'ont pas eu besoin de
promesses
ouais ben simon largement way et où l'on
prêté aux supporteurs de l'om qui est la
promesse que vous leur avez fait est
qu'on a gagné la coupe d'europe on l'a
gagné ouais mais il ya bien vous n'avez
pas tenu quand même à laquelle je sais
pas je vous demande normand et à
mitterrand il ya des promesses que vous
lui avez fait et vous n'avez pas de
pauvres malheureux non non je sais pas
je me renseigne la lutte est vachement
vos promesses vers un tapis non oui mine
de rien bah oui mais pourquoi mine de
rien c'est pas ben non c'est pourquoi
mine de rien c'est pas mine de rien
c'est oui il me débecte vous êtes
vraiment un mec incroyable
vous avez été chanteur d'abord l'argent
mène donc jusqu'au quai avec beaucoup
j'étais étudiant et donc j'étais patient
trouver les paroles de la chanson
c'était déjà quand même bien tout est
une philosophie qui étaient contenues
dans cette chanson est piqueté ap y
apposer les paroles de la chanson sexy
rien mais peu importe mes paroles
souvent je dis n'importe quoi si mes
idées sont un peu folle vrai ou faux ne
t'en fais pas c'est bien oui c'est toute
une philosophie des accords c'est la
salers et 1966 oui massif à la vraie la
philosophie des paroles des chansons de
son intérieur était pas tout le monde
excuse moi je peux t'en donner notre que
ce réussir sa vie car il était très bien
avec sur sa vie ah oui c'était le
contraire de réussir dans la vie
oui
tu as donc on peut tirer une phrase de
tout un palmarès pour démontrer qu'un
mec est ce aussi où cela vous avez été
chanteur dont comme d'annuaires homme
d'affaires oui est ce que c'est vrai
bernard tapie qu'avec toutes les
entreprises que vous avez racheté pour 1
franc symbolique vous auriez pu vous
payer un paquet de clopes
non mais le franc symbolique c'est
pareil c'est une image des vivres en
personne vous donne son entreprise pour
un front si brad ya des mecs à ces cons
on arrivait et nous avec des fusils
mitrailleurs on les mettait sur la tête
dans les banques lui benoît boîte pour 1
franc
donc c'est qu'il y avait peut-être
autour un certain nombre de choses donc
il vendait un franc mais il wendel et
des travailleurs des voix la part de
tous les boulots vous avez fait c'est
lequel qui rapporte le plus en argent
ouais évidemment chef d'entreprise quand
ça marche c'est évidemment mais
aujourd'hui ça va financièrement parce
que vous devez annuler vos dettes sont
gelées battre est réduit par le fils non
faussée jusqu'au 18 mars et tranquille
ouais hein 18 mars il
c'est énorme on va voir la fête
on va voir et de toucher un gros pack et
la berd va tous récupérés soit gens qu
il ya un milliard d'euros les trois
nanas regarde vraiment ça vous emmerde
que je récupère non pas du tout alors le
nom n'a pas du tout mais franchement
franchement non mais franchement à ça
dans le dans le sujet qui veut racheter
le le le
étant tu dois récupérer les sous qu'il
fera à chaque fois sa peine sans
frontières si j'ai beaucoup d'argent et
j'en ai aperçu de membres et abat fier
de faire un film what
moi aussi je paie à table et tu t'en as
marre et on va faire on va faire des 1
tous les gens qui sont là ont vu mon
film donc ça tombe bien c'est eux qui
l'ont vu ou alors il n'y a plus cette
ressource est bernard vous ne manquez
beaucoup que c'est moi j'aimais bien
quand ils viennent sinclair avec le pull
en mohair anny blatt le gros mont-blanc
et vous allez l'avoir le dimanche soir
c'est un vrai bonheur pour moi il est
voué bruel c'était sympathique cette
source est le seul qui a dit des choses
pas gentilles c'était moi quand même
vrai elle m'avait un peu taquiné je
l'avais un peu taquiné sur ce monde
quartier ah oui j'ai oublié la vente
quartier y avait le mont blanc le but là
ni bhl a dû oublier la montre cartier
alors dites-moi l'asservissement
maintenant on a envie d'avoir dans
bernard arnault on a envie d'avoir votre
avis sur ce qui se passe l'histoire de
juppé par exemple en pensez quoi la jupe
est qui qui se fait condamner par les
juges
et puis le présent la public qui dit que
c'est un type formidable ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'il vit ouais les
magistrats sont maintenant vraiment
devenu indépendant n'y a aucun doute là
dessus aucun et par conséquent tous les
éléments qui leur donnent l'impression
qu'on leur force la main ou qu'on veut
les pousser dans un système qui dépasse
le cadre précis de la loi il devient de
féroces moi même je les payais pour
avoir fait le con comme ça en pensant
aussi que l'on pouvait faire le malin ou
ça sert à rien vraiment et la faire dans
la sphère ça les magistrats qui ont subi
des menaces pour une leurs bureaux
visités
vous pensez que c'est possible ça avoue
non non non non il est mais je n'adore
pas ce qui était dit non les yeux dans
les yeux et je me suis dit mais vous y
croyez vous moi je vous dis je ne sais
pas non pourquoi pas mais la virée des
trains à la mer qui est dès qu'ils aient
eu des gens qui essaient de tirer le
jugement avant le jugement
ça c'est plutôt dans votre boulot qu'il
faut trouver les gens capables de faire
ça dans les milieux politiques dans les
milieux politiques
ça va rien changer ils prennent le
jugement ils savent qu'il existe et
qu'il est bon donc c'est pas c'est pas
ça je dis pas qui a pas eu de trucs mais
ça peut pas être le fait des gens
concernés directement par ce procès ça
c'est sûr et vous trompez pas si les
politiques aujourd'hui bourg là dessus
pour dire yeux on veut savoir ce qui
s'est passé ce qui sent pas que vous la
voyez vous
il est arrivé le loup c'est pour arriver
à dire ouais la décision n'a pas été
prise sereinement vous avez compris
pourquoi ils font tous la can et pour
dommages que vous fassiez pas un petit
peu de commentaires politiques de temps
en temps comme ça à la télévision et oui
juste histoire de rigoler ouais parce
que vous connaissez bien les trucs par
les garder car à bah oui un peu dix mois
alors le pen en paca
j'y croyais pas une seconde non ah ouais
penser que c'est encore un épouvantail
qu on nous agite pour la dernière fois
non non je pense que c'est un vrai
danger à temps et puis alors je vous
signale que tout ou toute attitude qui
consisterait à dire non donc on fait
rien ce serait criminel
j'y crois pas franchement franchement
j'y crois pas et je pense que muselier
va le battre
ah oui c'est mon d'ailleurs parce que
vous êtes plus pote avec muselier donc
et usb frères pères avant ou plus
qu'avec vauzelle qui a beaucoup plu et
socialiste n'a pas ce que j'ai fait
beaucoup à vos ailes qui lui m'a
beaucoup fait chier alors que j'ai rien
fait à muselier qu'elle c'est sympa avec
moi et voilà à quoi ça tient
donc voila moi je m'en fous le reste ça
pas d'intérêt il est comme ça oui il est
un peu comme ça tu peux compter sur lui
quand tu as besoin de rien alors tu es
mon soulier d'or
je vais bien me marrer au bistrot avec
lui au bar bien jean sarkozy président
en tout cas c'est quand même pas une
hypothèse dénuées de tout fondement
apparemment quand on voit les sondages
ça a l'air d'être bien parti pour lui
enfin j'ai l'impression au mois d'août
souhaitez-vous sarkozy que j'avais pas
de ce bord là dois je regarde ça avec
mes enfin d'après ce que voit il ya déjà
des sondages qui ont l'air de le placer
très largement devant tout le monde mais
ça vous le savez où vous le craignez
sarkozy faisait peur qu'une fois au
pouvoir ils deviennent un petit peu trop
autoritaire n'y a personne qui peut
devenir trop autoritaire dans ce pays
qui est ingérable avez bien lu on veut
tout changer toujours médailles que vous
bougez un truc tout le monde gueule
ouais faire le malin c'est très bien
comme terroriste personne peut être
autoritaire pète un peu comme ça répond
pas longtemps comme avec les gosses de
maintenant vous les voilà ya plus qu il
ya plus de papas et mamans autoritaire y
en a mais bon cela ils sont vite remis
par le juge du coin on ne peut pas
vraiment bien alors dites moi alors on
va terminer sur votre âge parce que dans
la pièce de nous raconter pendant toute
la soirée un ben oui je suis non 43 même
bien servi quand vous avez quoi pour
rester conserver comme ça que cela
demeure une belle pause et baghriche
d'abord comme un fou
moi je vois pas ça sera à wimby vais pas
vous filmez je ne boit pas une goutte
d'alcool je subis par siret et je fais
un tout petit peu l'amour
ah ouais ça fatigue de faire l'amour ça
fait vieillir prématurément battue doit
le savoir
ah bon
je peux aller
m
agnès saurat
asham
s'il vous plaît
mise en scène de jean luc moreau
et maintenant c'est fini
[Musique]
du plaisir
et
ni kouassi véronique jannot
[Musique]
bonsoir
c'est super il ya plein de mauvaises ce
soir l'émission démarre très bien
1 alors en plus chaleureux bernard là il
ya du lourd là incroyable
elles se connaissent elle se touche en
fait pas tout mais on a déjà travaillé
ensemble mais vous êtes au petit théâtre
de paris au théâtre de paris vous pas
honte personnes de plus - ouais alors
vous êtes donc chers véronique jannot au
petit théâtre de paris où vous reprenez
des fameux monologue du vagin a jamais
émanant de la chatte corrigeront donc à
la célèbre pièce de revan cela comme
croisille et et celle hobson c'est comme
ça qu'on dit et c'est le salon laisser
dawson bien alors si c'est incroyable le
nombre de comédiennes qu'on joue et ses
monologues du vagin et fanny cottençon
il ya sophie duez de christine boisson
firmine richard
princess erika claire nebout nicole
calfan lisette malidor vanessa demouy ça
forcément lille et les femmes se
repassent comme ça la pièce est des
états unis aussi c'est une pièce qui
tourne dans le monde entier en fait
j'étais assez jolie oui mais je trouve
que c'est important qu'elles existent
comme ça à travers le monde parce
qu'elles racontent même chose
essentielle est essentielle
c'est un texte qui était composée par
eve ensler à partir d'interviews de
femmes de tous âges de toutes conditions
et de tous les pays donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très universel au sujet
de la femme autour du autour du vagin
laurent je suis désolé le mot choque
encore trente ans après débecte mais bon
allons-y et faisant la promo c'est son
côté [__] non mais c'est vrai que ouais
c'est ça
tu viens laurent l'origine du monde de
courbet non mais c'est vrai que trente
ans après la révolution sexuelle
on a du mal à parler du vagin ils
agissent tout le monde est un peu un peu
gêné comme ça hein même vous bernard
importance à londres en garde sérieuse à
chalon la vive du talent vagin bah oury
boutique vous dit comment tu quoi on le
dit justement les noms qu'on emploie
pour sa fougue et la la crainte vous
n'êtes public
l'amérique le move agen a commencé 123 x
ne s'est pas c'est page c'est pas joli
non ouais c'est vrai que d'ailleurs on
dit dans la pièce et nicole nicole
croisille le tri et elle lui dit on peut
le prétendre qu'on peut prononcer de
toutes les façons qu'on veut il
jamais dire par quel pays entre nous
bénisse ces familles ne l'est pas
terrible non plus six mais tu sais pas
quelle bassesse et clini way oui voilà
c'est un routier québécois prison mais
je suis fils gynécologue donc gérard
wyss et un moteur qui ne me choque pas
du tout au pénis je trouve ça très clean
parce que cela dépend du pénis
alors
oui donc voilà j'ai créé en 1996 à new
york aujourd'hui jouer simultanément
dans 30 pays donc c'est vraiment un truc
assez exceptionnel 1 la dernière
présence sur scène de notre amie
véronique jannot s'il ya longtemps et a
longtemps c'était dans pleins feux la
meinau c'était il ya douze ans 11
oui la pièce de kalinka absolument quand
on regarde votre carrière d'ailleurs on
voit que vous avez touché à tout mais
sans vraiment vous investir à part la
télévision c'est pas ça c'est que je
m'investis en fait sur sur le sur le
moment j'ai pas de plan de carrière mais
j'ai pas de plan de vie non plus donc
les rencontres les opportunités qui font
les choses exactement par exactement je
m'enthousiasme exactement votre vie
enfance dorée à la campagne vous aviez
chercher du lait chaud à la ferme
votre jugement s'appelait flicka vous
souvenez tout ça et oui oui agi d'un
jeune enfant très belle enfance et puis
vous êtes devenue comédienne
complètement par hasard puisque votre
mère envoyez votre photo à un annuaire
de cinéma complètement comme ça et
cécile aubry est tombé sur ces photos
vous n'aviez même pas 15 ans et vous
êtes devenu la partenaire de son fils
dans le jeune femme avec mehdi le fils
de cécile aubry mais déjà à l'époque
c'est marrant parce que vous êtes
toujours des plans b vous mais toujours
des plans de secours
déjà à l'époque vous disiez si ça marche
pas de façon tant pis je suis forte en
langage fait autre chose
bah oui en anglais après j'ai fait du
théâtre vous avez fait l'école des
femmes le rôle d'agnès âge net
et puis vous été rattrapé par les
feuilletons télé c'est à dire qu'en fait
si on regarde votre carrière
on s'aperçoit qu'à chaque fois vous été
rattrapé par la télé il paul et virginie
aurélie et victorien voilà donc là je
suis le théâtre ça s'est arrêté vous y
revenez maintenant mais ça s'est arrêté
après l'expérience de long qui vous
choisit parmi 250 comédienne pour former
avec lui le nouveau couple du cinéma
français vous signez un contrat avec lui
alain delon dit à l'époque un exemple
voilà vous saurez la star de demain
harmonie on en apprend des choses dans
ces voies bien sûr tous les trois en
trois films et voilà vous deviez d'après
lui la star de demain mais le toubib n'a
pas été un grand succès le succès qu'il
escomptait ouais donc en fait on n'en a
fait qu'un autre mais c'est pareil dans
la chanson vous avez fait la chanson
avec voulzy qu'on adore tous et après
fini aussi à chaque fois la télé vous
rattrape par exemple fait pause-café ça
marche très bien en fait ça vous devenez
je vais le mazars tout le monde la
connaît mais c'est vrai que voilà la
télé vous a toujours rattraper mais les
août carrière vous avez abandonné assez
rapidement c'est l'impermanence c'est
pas parce que vous avez peur de dépendre
d'une seule activité non c'est sûr que
c'est assez déstabilisant pour obtenir
un petit peu flippant fait de dépendre
effectivement d'une seule activité
c'est mieux quand on a plusieurs cordes
à son décès une façon de vous protéger
en fait c'est pas conscient mais il ya
sûrement quelque chose que je pense moi
c'est pareil avec les mecs vous avez
peur des dépôts renommée vernis mais
c'est vrai véronique a peur de dépendre
d'un seul homme c'est vrai vous dit j'ai
envie de poser ma tête sur une épaule
mais j'ai peur aussi que les pôles se
retire brusquement c'est vrai mais oui
j'appose mais j'ai un petit peu en
apesanteur voilà là parce que j'ai peur
toujours ce que leur que l'homme s'en
aillent et qu'ils vous laissent tout
seul pour vous poser jamais vraiment la
tête
non parce que mais parce que peut-être
les projets déposés j'ai été trahi donc
mais on est tout pareil ouais oh non
elle vous laisse tomber la les autres
non alors il ya qu une fois vous avez
posé votre tête sur une épaule
malheureusement c'était celle de didier
pironi ça s'est mal terminée c'est
peut-être ça aussi qui vous a un petit
peu guéri je dirais des aventures c'est
pas c'est pas ça parce que c'est pas un
abandon c'est la vie qui a décidé que
bon bah voilà quelques ce qui était
boehner devait se transformer en malheur
mais donc c'est pas ça qui mais j'aime
pas trop parler de de tout ça parce que
c'est des cdd moment les moments
douloureux mais c'est aussi des moments
où je dis on pleure toujours sur ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a aimé on pleure
forcément beaucoup plus fort parce que
quand on a vécu très fort quelque chose
et c'est vrai que ce serait dur et plus
longtemps serait sûrement été formidable
et puis peut-être que ce ça n'aurait pas
été formidable ça va durer plus
longtemps
on ne peut pas savoir est ce que c'est
cette peur finalement de vous poser je
dirais une qui fait que vous n'ayez
jamais eu d'enfant je dirais que c'est
la vie qui en a décidé comme ça ouais
voilà qu'elle soit davantage si vous
êtes resté une enfant parce que tant que
tel ça se voit il suffit de vous
regarder tant qu'on a pas d'enfant on
est un enfant et vous êtes une femme ans
j'ai trois croix dessus une femme enfant
parce qu'effectivement je n'ai jamais eu
la responsabilité d'avoir un enfant
c'est une réelle responsabilité de
mettre au monde un enfant surtout
surtout aujourd'hui je trouve
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que je devrais
faire un enfant je suis pas sûr que je
serai le choix d'en faire un vous êtes
pressé très juvénile trop alors votre
équilibre vous l'avez trouvée c'est
extraordinaire dans le bouddhisme et
vous dites c'est assez vous allez
m'expliquer ça je suis catholique de
conduction bouddhiste ça veut dire quoi
ça mais ça veut dire que j'ai été élevé
dans la religion catholique j'ai fait ma
confirmation la première communion et
mais que j'ai découvert
je dirais le bouddhisme en tout cas la
philosophie bouddhiste plus tard parce
que pour moi c'est une fille vous êtes
boutiste aussi parce qu'un homme elle
avait envie d'ailleurs voilà j'ai ici
ses frères séparés avec natacha des
bouddhistes les 15 films bouddhisme et
natacha de mon association s'agit bel et
bien sûr je tapais bien sûr et le foot
de bouddhisme c'est une philosophie demi
avant et le dalaï lama dit lui même
pratiquer le bouddhisme en plus
n'allez pas renier notre religion pour
ça gers et c'est une leçon de tolérance
davantage si vous n'êtes pas été obligés
de vous raser la tête vous au moins
parce que dernier comme celle qui sera
sa tête c'est parce qu'elle c'est un
engagement religieuse couché avec les
[__]
c'est quoi le principe de base du
bouddhisme aba'a par les tongs c'est
quoi on veut vraiment faire quelque
chose d'extrêmement constructif et
d'autant plus constructif qu on le fait
d'abord pour les autres parce que c'est
un choix de vie un choix de vrai chemin
de croix y ait un oui c'est vraiment une
chose que bouddhiste
on revient quand tu veux de bercy je
regardais le samedi prochain pour un sou
non tout le monde croit que le
bouddhisme c'est au contraire ses côtés
des jeunes tout ça maintenant
transformer oui c'est compliqué c'est
très bon pour mais quand on l'a dans le
coeur c'est vrai que c'est vrai non
c'est vrai que c'est n'diaye les
défenseurs de la seule façon d'apporter
la paix au monde et d'apprendre soi-même
à vivre en paix bien sûr voilà c'est
tout tennis et john lennon le champion
sale bête avant de la faire dans la rue
pas désarmer tous les pays du monde on
compte des armes pas l'homme de toute
façon toutes les guerres continueront et
surtout surtout comme disait le poète et
mon où vivent vivons donc heureusement
sans arrière ce qui nous haïssent aimons
nous les uns les autres dans des boîtes
échangistes s'extraire et pourquoi il
est bon il c'est vrai pas finalement
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez commencé
par dire que c'est la tolérance
il ya des maisons hélas hélas hélas vous
êtes en train de dire que ce n'est pas
possible de s'aimer les uns les autres
dans une maison où ils s'échangent tous
bords un ami j'ai pas dit qu il a dit
l'échangisme
l'indicé charges y en a mais bien des
bouddhistes échanger sur mon nom
sûrement il y en a même je voudrais plus
qu'ailleurs
alors est ce qu'on a dit qu'elle était
né à annecy oui je crois que monde s'en
branle bélanger on peut dire aussi ses
quatre jeux qu'on peut dire aussi c'est
que véronique a été levée à seynod n'est
ce pas bien alors maintenant on va
continuer on va faire une petite
interview alerte bleue
claire taux de la route sont de grands
classiques de cette émission est ce que
vous préférez draguer ou faire draguer
la ferme accueille c'est pas comme ça
qui fera quoi embrassez vous faire
embrasser les deux mon capitaine
caresser ou faire caresser la tête alors
[Musique]
qu'elle est le lieu idéal pour faire
l'amour donne ça dépend des jours y a
pas lieu idéal c'est répondu ça dépend
de l'humeur ça dépend de ce qu'on vit de
commander à ce moment là il n'y a pas
deux alors est-ce que vous avez besoin
de faire l'amour pour aimer ou des mets
pour faire l'amour j'ai besoin d'aidé
pour faire l'amour qu'elle monte
vous commencez par faire l'amour après
vous aimez qua non non non pour faire un
mec qui bosse bien mais qu'un infidèle
ou un mec qui baisent mal mais que
fidèle
rivest vieille qui est un fidèle parce
que je pars du principe qu'il vaut mieux
être à plusieurs sur le mode à faire que
tout seul sur une mauvaise voie
et nous tous les autres dans des boîtes
de changer un truc terrible c'est les
hommes qui brandissent l'étendard de la
fidélité et qui en fait qui vous ennuie
ce rodez qui sont fidèles
vous préférez quelqu'un que tu m'amuses
voilà messieurs savoir non mais tu te
dis tu as du mal ça va
non mais vous préférez voir avec celle
de bonne humeur quand ils rentrent c'est
ce que vous dites est la série qui soit
et qui sera bientôt final 60 est sympa
c'est jeannot bien vous préférez
sérieusement préféreriez qui vous quitte
pour un amour pour une femme une femme
moi je suis pas un homme super g dont
voici ma femme me quitter pour une femme
serait moins jaloux pour un homme tu
serais ravi surtout parce que si ça
parce que ça prouvera que j'ai des
joutes et les femmes c'est quand même
pas terrible
vous préférez qui couche avec une autre
en pensant à vous avec vous en pensant à
une autre 6 avec les nôtres en pensant
préféré ça et tant qu'à faire ce que je
fais avec une autre très bon si jamais
la lumière voulait qu'on est les salines
et
où est un nom bcbc faire je préférais
serre ges que tu peux baisser un peu le
nez discuter entre vous dans l'eau du
bassin de copains qui tient le pari du
blanc à côté du cap pas
cette feuille blanche est très présente
et la non arrivée il ya que du beau
monde à une soirée exceptionnelle le 8
mars à l'occasion du v day donc de
nombreuses personnalités seront au
théâtre de paris alors le le jour du vc
le jour du vagin c'est ça non le jour
valentine'day en fait c'est une choix
qui avait un jour du vagin moi c'est un
jour qui est fait pour pour pour lutter
contre toutes ces femmes qui ne sont pas
aimés comme et comme les valentins
c'est pour dans les fonds sont reversés
justement et des associations qui
s'occupent de femmes battues mal traitée
à travers le monde et c'est une c'est
une association c'est un mouvement qui a
été initiée par eve ensler justement
qu'ils occupent
l'auteur des monologues du vagin qui se
bat depuis cinq ans à travers le monde
pour justement aider à la condition
féminine et et
et se batte pour elle
[Musique]
on va vous laisser guider je suis désolé
mais il faut que j'aille me tourne en
syrie n'est à bientôt véronique
et maintenant
mais
mais c'est bernard kouchner
ah ils se font des bisous
analekta
ils se connaissent bien on attendait on
va faire une pause bisous là là on est
obligé laurent bousses bisous
avec
mais numérique
accor
non il m'a paru
[Musique]
ah ça fait du bien à une bonne cause
bisou à elancourt s'insultent avoir
plusieurs femmes
ça y est atteint pascale roberts quand
je lisais quand je lisais signer mon
dessinées revues si vous saviez comme
une feuille et permettent de bernard je
me demande ce que je fais là là avec
qu'est ce qui lie à bernard commence mal
pas du tout pourquoi métier quand on va
chez le toubib on attend c'est
la beetle pendant maintenant ça
s'appelle tous les deux bernard minet ce
qui a tant fait pas rentrer maintenant
ces journées bout dit bernard kouchner
je dis ce que je pense c'est ma façon de
faire de la politique pas prendre les
gens pour des cons bon ouais ben
apparemment ça marche un résultat dans
paris match le 8 janvier 2004 numéro un
numéro un au classement des
personnalités politiques préférées des
français 68% pour kouchner dans le point
c'est que 61% mais c'est pas mal quand
même
dans le journal du dimanche d'être le
premier homme politique du classement
des 50 français préférés des français
dans le vrai journal vous êtes meilleur
potentiel électoral présidentiel pour la
gauche ex-aequo avec sarkozy devant
chirac est méritée méritez vous trouvez
vous par là un homme est vraiment là
vraiment il ya beaucoup de gens qui
peuvent être dans le coeur des gens
apprécié et aimé ça ça veut dire que
c'est lui murray lui c'est l'action qui
l'amène là c'est un mec qui a fait plein
de trucs mais pas seulement avec
sympathie
voilà pourquoi j c'est mérité il est
trop aimer c'est terrible non mais c'est
marrant mais enfin qu'est ce que je dois
faire dans ces cas c'est à dire presque
parler les autres il faut avoir une
espèce d'air un petit peu comme ça un
peu modeste quand même
voilà vous faites bien c'est pas bien
sinon plus le problème c'est le ps bien
sur evans et c'est toujours pareil quoi
c'est à dire oui à toi que je vais dire
ça un oui mais c'est pas un problème
offrir au même instant moi dans ma d'or
pour l'épauler au prix justement tu veux
pas dire ça un moment où les élections
régionales
bernard kouchner n'est même pas sur
l'organigramme de campagne du parti
cirque eux-mêmes jack lang et pourtant
dieu sait si ballon sur le ps jack lang
il est porte parole d'aena remis les
porte parole vous vous n'avez rien du
tout pour ces régionales sont peut-être
raison non ils vont sûrement tort je
vous avais 68% des français et leur
maladie danse après il s'en fout ouais
m'enfin si t'as pas un parti la
présidente s'est pas
pas facile laurent tu verras la donne va
changer là parce que le fait d'avoir mis
les présidentielles exactement au même
moment que les législatives
ça va beaucoup changer de choses parce
que s'ils lisent si les candidats aux
différentes élections s'aperçoivent que
le meilleur pour faire gagner leur camp
ouais c'est bernard kouchner ou c'est
jacques lang ces machins vous croyez pas
que les structures du parti vont rester
rigide et figé comme ça là les mecs qui
veulent aller à la gamelle et ils vont
décider de choisir celui qui a le plus
de chances de les faire gagner
ils ont viré hollande tu penses je pense
que hollande aujourd'hui il est nommé 10
ans sérieusement ou pas si je le sens
mais tu te trompes tu crois qu'il veut
et elle a préféré perdre sans toi oui
non parce que c'est que ça c'est
intéressant préféré perdre sans kouchner
ou gagner avec ou cp savant prises non
non c'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer il ya des partis politiques on
peut dire hélas mais ça existe c'est ma
et là c'est comme ça que fonctionne la
démocratie est encore une gauche et une
droite dames 1 oui avec peut-être de
temps en temps des oppositions qu'on
comprend mal mais il ya une gauche et
une droite qui a une façon de voir les
choses qui est différente vu du parti
socialiste que de la droite et les gens
vont voter
hélas ou avait ni raison pour qu'ils en
fonction de ce choix la fausse droite en
fonction d'un parti les élections
présidentielles c'est un rendez vous
avec un homme et les électeurs alors
maintenant est-ce qu'ils ont le courage
d'aller affronter tout le reste c'est
toute la question je suis content d'en
débattre avec toi en public car j'espère
que tu auras cette volonté là quoi que
fasse le parti socialiste parce qu'il ya
plein de gens qui attendent ça
et voilà non je sais que et l'on voit
bien la flapie vient d'introniser
bernard kouchner j'ai un retour dans les
toilettes c'était faisable la 68 % il
pense que moi je suis amusé en veulent
sans doute parce que au moment de la
canicule se fait un petit peu défendu le
le gouvernement actuel dans un premier
temps ensuite sur la guerre d'irak
n'aviez pas la position du parti
socialiste qui est favorable à la guerre
d'irak
peut-être c'est pour ça que nos jours
n'est pas favorable à la guerre d'irak
j'étais favorable à une action qui
permettait au peuple irakiens de se
débarrasser de son dictateur qu'il
assassine est depuis des années je
maintiens cette place j'avais dit la
seule et j'ai dit richard massif c'est
saddam hussein c'est vrai oui bien alors
il ya aussi autre chose c'est que vous
avez failli participer au colloque de la
fondation de l'ump
ça les a énervé c'est normal la période
électorale se prêtait mal à une
distribution un peu différente des
meetings de gauche et des mythiques de
droite on peut le regretter et j'ai la
prochaine can j'ai pas les noms je suis
pas allée de partie vous avez demandé à
monsieur jérôme monod à jérôme monod de
me pardonner il m'a pardonné
alors à ces sujets là au sujet du
colloque de la fondation de l'ump
françois hollande donc le secrétaire
général a déclaré je n'ai rien contre le
fait de débattre encore faut-il savoir
combien on est payés oui elle sait pas
ce qu'il voulait dire ça pour jérôme
monod et la façon dont il fit danser en
paie pas pour moi c'est le personne ne
pouvait penser que j'étais payé par
jérôme monod pour aller au collège
parler du danger
il a dit ça vous savez pourquoi il a dit
ses impacts enfin il a dit ça à cause de
la sphère total vous êtes au courant
enfin lui et je le crois prétend que ça
n'est pas ça qui sa pensée a été déformé
oui il a fait allusion non je crois pas
franchement c'est pas qu'il faisait
allusion à votre rapport vous avez fait
pour total sur le travail forcé en
birmanie alors je sens qu'on va parler
de ça et varna bernard je ne peux pas ne
pas vous en parler et vous donner le nom
maintenant combien d'années on va parler
de ça sans aller voir pendant combien
d'années on va se demander si les autres
ont vu ce qu'on n'a pas vu donc total a
fait construire en birmanie un gazoduc
et a été accusé de pratiquer les travaux
forcés en incluant des enfants donc il
ya un procès d'un certain nombre de
victimes de la dictature birmane contre
total et un jour maître jean veil le
fils de simone veil qui est avocat de
total vous commande enfin la société
bernard kouchner conseil une étude un
rapport sur la situation là bas et vous
êtes payés pour ça 25000 euros
vous partez en birmanie et vous
rapporter des conclusions qui
blanchissent total vous dites je suis
sûr à 95 % que les gens de total ne sont
pas des esclavagistes à leur première
question est ce que vous saviez que ce
rapport serait utilisée dans le procès
qui oppose total aux victimes
je n'y avais pas d'allusions au procès
le rapport a été commandé pour juger de
la situation médico social et de la
façon dont total prenait en charge les
populations dans la région du pikes je
suis allé là bas et je n'ai ni accepté
ni signer quoi que ce soit avant de me
rendre compte si selon ma conviction
les accusations contre total étaient
fondées ou non mais vous avez répondu
dans ce que vous venez de dire oui les
victimes de la dictature birmane qui
elle n'est pas douteuse une dictature
solide avec une jeune militaire soutenu
par des tas de pays dont l'un financé en
son temps d'air que j'ai dénoncé que je
continue de dénoncer
ah non pas pour raison d'être mais pour
habitude enraciné partout dans tout le
pays d'ex clavat jc c'est à dire de
rafler les personnels enfin les
personnes et sûrement les personnels
sont les gens des villages etc et de les
forcer à travailler - s'est
malheureusement répandue aussi dans la
zone de total le problème est donc de
savoir si dans la zone de total total à
utiliser comme main d'oeuvre forcée
sciemment
un personnel qui étaient en réalité des
villageois de la région où on a voulu
faire dire que dans la zone de total ça
se déroulait est-ce que total était
fermé oui moi je pense que non mais
voilà je continue à battants des c'est
pas simple parce que lorsque dans une
zone celle de total il se déroule comme
ça des exactions
est ce qu'ils peuvent intervenir tout de
suite est-ce qu'ils ont fermé les yeux
est ce qu'ils envient du temps est ce qu
ils ont fait exactement ce qu'il fallait
ça on n'en sais rien moi j'ai pas été
fait un rapport sur les événements de 94
j'ai dit que je parlais de la situation
médicale grâce à total qui s'améliore
grandement on a diminué par huit la
mortalité infantile c'est un simple
chiffre qui parle quand même et je ne
pense pas qu'avec les lois françaises
avec l'esprit qui les anime la compagnie
total ait pu être esclavagiste ou
utiliser le travail forcé voilà voilà
alors peu attendait ça veut pas dire
qu'on n'écoute pas les pleins de l'autre
côté qu'on doit pas la prendre en compte
ce qui s'est passé chez les victimes et
ceux là il faut les écouter aussi et on
verra on verra bien un jour et c'est
très bien ça fait longtemps que ça dure
alors assez avec la fédération
internationale des droits de l'homme
regrette que vous ayez prêter votre nom
à une opération de relations publiques
de total au moment où cette compagnie
doit rendre des comptes à la justice
alors c'est pas moi qui pose des
questions si la fédération
internationale droits de l'homme dans
quelles conditions se sont effectuées
vos rencontres avec les villageois
absolument moi seul quand je voulais
avec les gens d'accord que je jugeais
fond voilà annoncé très tôt dès bernard
ça suffit pas de dire ça parce que
j'aurais pu être gruger quand même on
aurait pu me présenter les personnes
devant moi bien entendu tout ça j'en
suis pas complètement innocent mais ça
fait longtemps que je connais et ces
pays et les violations des droits de
l'homme j'ai passé ma vie à les dénoncer
jolie j'ai même dénoncé les violations
sans savoir qu'ils étaient 80 qu'arriver
à total seulement alors est ce que est
ce que très difficile et traducteurs
étaient fournis par total
non c'est moi qui l'ait choisie c'est
dans les gens du personnel médical car
n'oublions pas que mon enquête était
médical qui parlait anglais il y en a
beaucoup moins et c'est moi qui sans
avoir été en rien ni contraints ni suivi
déterminé mon trajet bien parce que le
partenaire américain de total en
birmanie qui s'appelle locale
le patron a reconnu quand même qu'ils
avaient du travail forcé n'ont pas pas
si si si absolument
non non attendez je pense qu'on peut pas
dire ça comme ça parce qu'il ya les gens
qui sont au siège des gens qui sont sur
le terrain des gens qui à côté total et
qui étaient partenaires n'ont pas été
attaqués dont il ya plein de choses sur
lesquelles il faudrait enquêter l'ennui
c'est que total et les autres d'ailleurs
ne laissez pas libre accès à cette
région pour les militants de la radio
mais qu'il faut que ce soit fait gagner
il faut que les gens puissent en arriver
n'importe quoi il ya eu cette réaction
c'est parce qu'en 94 chez dagorno vous
ai signé la préface d'un dossier noir
sur la birmanie où vous disiez la france
commerce avec des généraux les généraux
de la junte qui dirige la birmanie que
vous nommiez narco dictateur via des
industries pétrolières donc c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que 10 ans après c'est a
surpris tout le monde de vous voir non
pas non pas blanchir l'agent je
comprends très bien que l'on parle sans
savoir
rien n'est fait oui est-ce que si
c'était à refaire vous êtes devant jean
veil le fils de simone un ami à vous il
vous dit va me faire cette mission là
bas c'est important est-ce que vous
accepteriez encore aujourd'hui non j
accepterai pas d'y aller seul la bêtise
c'est d'y être allé seul c'est de ne pas
y être allé avec un autre témoin qu'on
aurait accusé comme moi après quarante
ans de lutte pour les droits de l'homme
de mentir mais je pense que j'aurais pas
dû y aller seul mais ça c'est pas grave
à la coop
parce que j'ai quand même obtenu
j'espère que ce sera on pourra s'en
rendre compte que les associations
droits de l'homme en particulier
américaines se rendent sur le télé
horaire et ça oui mais ça c'est
formidable ça veut dire qu'ils vont voir
eux même peut-être qu'après tout je me
suis trompé peut-être pas d'accord et la
théorie qui consiste à essayer
d'approcher la vérité ou de faire une
démarche permanente pour essayer de dire
sa vérité ça non je ne regrette pas a
sûrement pas non message de total pour
vous remercier d avoir cité 18 m ils ont
pas besoin de ça en france ils sont en
situation de monopole maintenant c'est
comme l'urss maintenant le capitalisme
nous revient au consortium de l'urss
elle est extraordinaire c'est que tous
les gens que j'ai rencontrés de tous les
gens que j'ai rencontrés j'en ai
rencontré beaucoup
elle affirmait que total était
responsable n'y en avait pas un qui
s'était rendu au chanteur
j'ai nommé le savaient pourquoi je dis
ça c'est parce que on a dit il ya dix
minutes que vous aviez de bonnes chances
d'être présent la république il ya une
autre piste devant vous qui êtes
représentant de l'onu à bagdad et je ne
voudrais pas que pour une histoire comme
ça votre carrière politique soit tu as
des riverains piger bien quand tu as eu
mais ils m'ont retenu en équipe i do
merci merci merci je sois sa fille comme
si quand même quand ils exagèrent
[Musique]
donc maintenant on en arrive
effectivement à l'irak et je pense que
si monsieur kofi annan lit ce livre qui
s'appelle les guerriers de la lécher
chez grasset il va il va vous nommez il
va vous nommez thaïs extraordinaire moi
j'ai gelé
voilà ce que j'ai fait au kosovo en gros
et voilà ce que je pourrais faire
revenir à quoi vous commencez donc ce
livre par le portrait de vos quatre amis
assassinés donc par un camion suicide à
bagdad sergio vieira de mello nadia
younès jean slim canon fiona watson et
puis tous les autres donc vous commencez
par la rendre hommage vous dites que
c'est le fascisme islamique qui les a
tués vous dites faux-pas faut pas se
faire d'illusion même si aujourd'hui
l'europe est un petit peu épargnés comme
ça en fait c'était la communauté
internationale qu'ils ont déclaré la
guerre
le jour de cet attentat oui mais
j'annonce en même temps que je ne
confonds pas je précise que je ne
confonds pas ce fascisme là avec
l'immense majorité vent et les islamique
l'un sur l'immense majorité des
musulmans qui eux modéré tolérant
attendent que l'on réagisse contre ce
qui est une oppression d'abord tournés
vers eux d'abord tournée vers les femmes
musulmanes d'abord tourné en particulier
en irak vers le peuple irakien voilà
alors après vous raconter le kosovo où
vous êtes représentant spécial du
secrétaire général de l'onu avec comme
feuille de route la fameuse résolution
1244 dont en fait même kofi annan
reconnaît qu'elle est impossible à
appliquer elle était écrite avec
habileté pour contenter tout le monde
comme souvent les résolutions malgré ça
et malgré ça et ça c'est tout à votre
honneur
à la sortie les élections que vous
organisez la base sont les élections les
plus démocratiques jamais organisé dans
les balkans voilà l'avis des autres
après mais oui enfin en tout cas elle
était surveillée et organisée de telle
façon que sur tous les kosovars pour la
première fois ont voté que toutes les
familles étaient là depuis 6 heures du
matin et c'était la première fois qu'on
leur demandait leur avis que c'était la
première fois qu'ils pouvaient voter
librement c'était ça le succès alors
voilà donc va revient le succès de la
communauté internationale vous raconter
votre expérience au kosovo des grands
moment d'héroïsme couche n'est rien
quand même que je signale à tous nos
amis
quand l'homme a le couteau que vous
marchez vers lui que le silence se fait
que que non mais c'est courageux quand
même le mec il aurait pu vous mettre un
coup de couteau jeudi je rigole pas non
c'était courageux de sa part de bien
vouloir me parler parce qu'il s'agit
d'un accueil très particulier et nous
étions venus pour aider ceux qui étaient
les victimes c'est vrai les kosovars et
nous sommes aperçus que les serbes qui
restait était à leur tour les victimes
n'avaient pas les protéger et lorsque
nous sommes arrivés il ya eu ce massacre
de grh qu avec 14 paysans assassinés
dans leur champ dont des enfants et qui
était une façon de saluer mon arrivée et
qui s'est déroulé de la même manière
avec mes successeurs est donc allé voir
ces serbes qui ne comprenaient pas et en
tout particulièrement le grand père du
petit enfant de 14 ans assassinée qui
comprenait pas ce que nous faisions là
sauf de conforter les assassins c'était
non seulement nécessaire mais c'est ça
la mission il faut parler aux gens et à
leurs côtés vous diriger vers lui non
mais attendez
voilà vous le prenez lanvaux brave je
les mets qui n'ont pas l'habitude
améliorées tirent des coups de
kalachnikov dans la gueule donc c'est
plutôt ouvriers faire j'ai revu les
photos et le film de l'enterrement de
ces pauvres gens et je revois encore le
visage du grand-père qui cette fois là
c'est lui-même dirigé vers moi enfin
faire ce que je représente est ainsi que
la délégation des nations unies et et
c'était enfin une méthode qui rend la
dignité
peut-être enfin en tout cas une approche
différente nous sommes chez les gens
s'étaient eux ce pays si vous connaissez
peut-être que ça marcherait mieux
bernard c'est simplement ce que j'essaye
de de dire bon enfin en tous les cas
vous êtes enceinte au kosovo donc
effectivement vous régler tous les
actions rioux s'est pas réglé par
exemple vous occuper des actions de
police de l'ordre public de la liberté
de la presse vous interdisez même un
journal on vous traite de proconsul à un
moment parce que le journal cite des
listes c'est à dire que quand on cite
ces gens ils vont sont assassinés
l'homme est donc un moment donné et je
suis pour la liberté de la presse mais
pas la liberté de distribuer une liste
de personnes à assassiner comment les
protège ton est donc c'est vrai les
militants des droits de l'homme une fois
plus m'ont dit que j'étais un dictateur
mais il n'y avait pas moyen de faire
autrement
a lyon je veux dire si vous avez été aux
affaires
avec ce que ça comporte effectivement
c'est ce que vu de joueurs du brésil en
ce moment lula il épaule voilà c'est
difficile il ya l'opposition il ya les
affaires quant à nos affaires ont fait
pas toujours comme on veut alors pour
raconter vous raconter les visites
diplomatiques clinton blair chirac vous
régis est la monnaie la justice enfin
voilà donc c'est vrai que ça vous donne
une capacité aujourd'hui peut-être à
partir du mois de juin pour vous occuper
de l'irak quand les américains parlent
et ils vont partir foutez moi je
voudrais d'abord que se livrent serve à
quelque chose
à travers le monde et c'est pour ça que
vous avez parlé de kofi annan il a été
le premier à l'avoir et et à le lire et
la position des nations unies j'espère
qu'il y aura une mission qui lui sera
confié position nouvelle à bagdad en
irak avec un mandat élargi et avec une
approche des populations qui souhaitent
un peu différente je dis pas que c'est
facile tu pas que c'est possible mais en
tout cas je sais vous savez la question
est simple est ce que on doit aimer les
gens qu'on aide et la réponse est vaut
mieux oui c'est mieux c'est pas forcé de
le faire mais ça se sent tout de suite
et si vous agissez en pays conquis ou de
manière à imposer ça s'impose pas la
démocratie ce sont nos offres de
convaincre les gens et de faire aimer la
méthode démocratique votre fameux droit
d'ingérence
à la lueur de l'opération américaine en
irak c'est à dire qu'on apporte la
démocratie avec des bombardiers whitney
temps et ça c'est pas du droit
d'ingérence c'est du pouvoir d'un gérant
guy pasquet scapa est-ce que là quand ça
vous arrange vous opérez pas un
glissement sémantique non c'est pas me
champ sémantique c'est une nette
attaques contre la méthode américaine
j'aimerais que évidemment il suffit pas
d'avoir le pouvoir il faut passer par
les nations unies au kosovo
l'europe et l'amérique était ensemble
ouais c'était formidable et ça marchait
très bien ça marchait très bien ça a
marché en irak
l'europe et les états unis étaient
séparés et hélas ça ne marche pas bien
ça marchera à terme ne croyais pas mais
je crois qu'il faut ressouder les les
pièces du puzzle et qu'il faut que les
nations unies soient chargées très
clairement de l'installation de la
démocratie en irak
les guerriers de la paix si chez grasset
ses aventures de bernard kouchner au
kosovo
comme vous êtes docteur quand même je
vous fais réputé interview check up
[Musique]
dors bernard kouchner vous êtes chez le
docteur a redit son conducteur
bonjour je vous ai pas fait attendre ça
va non ça va bien qu'est ce qui vous
donne envie de vomir dans le monde
actuel le mensonge
qu'est ce qui vous fait mal au coeur
dans le monde actuel la pression en
france qu'est ce qui vous donne mal à la
tête
la vie quotidienne y amener la vie
qu'est ce qui vous donne des boutons
dans le milieu politique
la même chose un ulcère je vous pose la
question c'est pareil ah non annoncée à
ça fait mal à leur sexe comme un ulcère
alors dans le milieu politique
aujourd'hui en france cette façon de
croire que quand une idée vient de
l'autre quand elle est forcément mauvais
personne n'y croit et pourtant on fait
toujours de céder à cette espèce de
guerre civile oui je crois que ça c'est
dommageable pour le pays et pour
l'estomac et page thomas particulier
mais pour le pays surtout quelle femme
politique vous donne la fière
aujourd'hui en france roselyne bachelot
ah oui elle vous excite
non je les aime bien ah oui j'ai des
convictions
pourquoi vous l'aimez bien parce que je
les aime bien je la trouve sympathique
et franche elle est marrante ce qui fait
le plus de gaz ces salons non non pas du
tout bon jeu le bien non je trouve
absolument primesautière a
merveilleusement habillé d'ailleurs
vivent là c'est trop ça
je suis déjà et je non non non je suis à
ce que je trouve de compliments tu le
compliment tout ça bien réveillé la
légende écroué à marquer l'injustice
aujourd'hui en france vous fait vraiment
mal au cul je crois que cette mesure qui
consiste à donner moins d'argent aux
jeunes femmes ont sans fin pour la
première naissance ou aux jeunes femmes
enceintes qui ont un besoin terrible
parce qu'elles n'ont pas de ressources
me paraît particulièrement inappropriés
et scandaleuse voilà bah écoutez le
check up est terminée ça va ça va ça va
vous voulez que je vous prescrive un peu
de viagra comme la dernière fois non
mais il m'a prescrit un truc comme ça tu
l'avais je n'ai pas pris fait partie
diot
bernard kouchner est bien de la paix
s'est invité chez grasset et la
boucherie
car à north mais je voudrais quand même
vous signalez le livre de jean s'est dit
mme k now
un des quatre de nos amis qui étaient au
kosovo uck et qui sont morts à bagdad ce
livre qui s'appelle maguer à
l'indifférence et qui par certains côtés
non seulement est un livre de combat
livre de militants manif très tendre et
très poétique
c'est vrai que c'est chez robert laffont
merci et maintenant voici juliette lewis
[Musique]
bonsoir je trouvais ça va et à la gueule
ça va bien merci
vous aimez paris ça va quoi c'est sûr
pourquoi est ce que j'aimerais tatari
vous avez un bon hôtel bien sûr hors
stade et ressemble peut-être c'était toi
je ne sais pas très bien dans la merde à
gare du nord
la traductrice c'est qui ces tasses mine
c'est est-ce mines bonsoir toujours là
incroyable excuse toi pour la dernière
fois laurent on lui doit de l'argent
d'ailleurs chez the beast has been used
the best
merci beaucoup dans welcome bien
alors juliette lewis votre premier grand
rôle au cinéma c'était 4 firent les
nerfs à vif de martin scorsese c'est
avec robert de niro nick nolte id
jessica lynch interprétation très
remarquée qui vous a valu deux
nominations aux oscars et aux golden
globes pour le meilleur second rôle
ensuite woody allen a fait appel à vous
pour mari et femme
albans et puis elle californien avec un
cahier avec brad pitt
il ya eu gilberte drake avec johnny depp
et leonardo dicaprio mais surtout tueurs
nés d'oliver stone qui vous a propulsé
en haut de l'affiché aujourd'hui vous
revenez avec blueberry dont on a parlé
la semaine dernière ici avec le
réalisateur jan kounen et avec le
premier rôle vincent cassel voilà alors
blueberry donc c'est dans la grande
tradition du western
mais en même temps c'est un film
fantastique qui traite du surnaturel ce
qui fait qu on a dit que c'était un
western chamanique
tu l'as pas vu le film un bernard c'est
un western ça commence comme blueberry
un film de cow-boys quoi très bien et
très bien réalisé d'ailleurs
et puis à une espèce de quête
initiatique où à l'aide de psychotropes
que possèdent les indiens le héros
blueberry en fait part à la recherche de
lui même et se trouve dans une espèce de
voyage un peu comme malcom lowry que mon
ami kouchner a bien connu dans son jonas
voilà alors dans le film vous avez un
rôle assez classique juliette vous êtes
la fille d'un grand propriétaire terrien
dont blueberry est amoureux et vous
partez avec lui dans sa quête
initiatique
alors il ya un truc extraordinaire dans
le film ce qui à votre père joeffrey
lewis donc le grand acteur de 10 trous
d2 et de sergio leone
c'était compliqué de tourner avec votre
votre père dans le film
oui enfin je pensais que ce serait
difficile
je ne pensais que ce serait un petit peu
étrange parce que nous sommes très
proches bien sûr c'est mon père mais en
fait c'est quelque chose
qui était très particulier nous
travaillons d'un même manière si vous
voulez tous les deux nous sommes
décontractée avec l'équipe sur le
plateau tous les deux et puis ensuite
parce que la caméra tourne
eh bien nous sommes très concentrés j'ai
trouvé que c'était est super de pouvoir
travailler en espagne avec mon père
alors il ya deux scènes extraordinaires
dans le film l'une où vous chantez danny
boy dans un saloon avec une robe très
jolie vous êtes vous fait ça très bien
et une ou deux scènes encore plus
extraordinaire où vous faites l'amour
sous une cascade dans l'eau avec vincent
cassel 1 et vous êtes tout nu et ça a
été difficile parce que on a
l'impression que vous restez lille demi
heure sous l'eau et ça a été compliqué
parce que vous étiez obligés de prendre
beaucoup de respiration comment ça c'est
fait ce tournant alors c'est pas très
pratique évidemment on peut pas vraiment
faire l'amour sous l'eau je pense pas
que ce soit possible mais en tout cas
c'est très beau parce que ça représente
à vie l'amour mais en fait on prend
notre respiration des 100 kg et
[Musique]
en ville il ya déjà des bruits qui
courent monde et qui a plus d'or dans
ces montagnes que dans toute la
californie
c'est bien ça qui fait peur et insolite
j'ai trouvé les montagnes toi tu es
amoureuse de lui
moi vachement bon
c'était promis dès lors je t'offre des
montagnes d'or je m'en fous si j'ai
cliqué peu
à suivre encore coke aux mateurs aux
katas qu'au foot la tête il avait certes
croyez mort s'est pas tu te dis jamais
amis
belga
et une automatique à montfort
où est le manuscrit
mais je trouverais ce qui s'est vraiment
passé costa rica luis enrique
mais la nouveauté
voilà les rituels
normalement
je ne veux pas pour rien
voilà nos mairies de jan kounen avec
vincent cassel michael madsen et
juliette lewis qui est notre invité ce
soir voilà film étonnant vraiment
étonnant parce que ça démarre encore une
fois comme un comme un western à ses
traditionnels puis sa part très très
loin dans dans l'inconscient et les
critiques sont très bonnes en france
très très bonne c'est super ça l es tu
vois si une star énorme mais quand on me
dit que les critiques sont bonnes et les
contournent c'est elle le croit surtout
base non mais c'est vrai en plus il se
trouve que c'est vrai
alors juliette lewis je tenais à los
angeles j'ai été élevé dans le milieu du
cinéma
puisque votre père comme je l'aï été
acteur émancipé à l'âge de 14 ans parce
qu'à un moment où vous pouviez plus
tourner et tout ce qu'on vous demandait
de tourner donc fallu que votre père
vous vous émanciper
et puis dès l'âge de 15 ans j'ai
commencé un petit peu à traîner comme ça
dans les boîtes de nuit
et puis vous avez été un petit peu
déstabilisé par des relations avec des
gens exceptionnels c'est vrai que vous
avez été successivement avec brad pitt
avec leonardo dicaprio et kouchner
mais ça c'est pas plus j'ai travaillé
avec des cabris mais je ne suis jamais
sortie avec lui c'est comme un frère
pour noah et brad pitt n'ont quand même
c'est comme une soeur 5 assists non je
crois que lorsque dans les 19 ans eh
bien on est très sérieux aux pensées
chose à très au sérieux maintenant j'ai
30 ans et je crois que bon moi j'ai
passé par toutes les étapes par
lesquelles tout le monde pas ça a été
encore 20 ans
je lirai seriez bon tout le monde
aimerait bien passer par l'étape brad
pitt est peut-être leonardo dicaprio
c'est mais malheureusement je pense pas
que ça soit le cas non alors pour pour
me permettre de m non mais je ne suis
pas passé devant et avec des prix et non
c'est ok alors nous devrons jouer
ensemble c'est tout mais alors pour que
mes fiches soit bien un jour qu'il reste
plus jamais d'erreur vous concernant à
un moment vous avez quand même un petit
peu pris de la drogue c'est un petit peu
c'est vrai ça c'est pas grave moi aussi
oui lorsque j'avais 20 ans prison vous
dit de jouer avait été toute ma vie et à
l'époque je ne voulais même plus le
faire c'est à dire comment vous êtes
retrouvé en n'ayant même plus envie
voilà c'est comme ça j'avais 20 ans je
sais très introverti était très sérieuse
alors c'est vrai que j'ai pris parce que
j'avais l'impression que je n'arrivais
pas à gérer ma vie voilà est-ce que
comme john travolta tom cruise nicole
kidman ou priscilla presley vous avez
trouvé votre salut dans l'église de
scientologie philosophie oui parce que
de nombreuses personnes ne savent pas
que rabat un philosophe il écrit je sais
que il a mauvaise réputation ici c'est
la seule religion il faut donner un rib
chesneau très très mauvais nantes c'est
vrai qu'il a une très mauvaise
réputation en europe
ron mais si c'est pas vrai l'histoire du
rif c'est pas vrai expliqué non c'est
pas vrai
dans le magazine direct m un jour ils
ont écrit qu'il fallait donner 10 % de
sens à l'heure l'église de scientologie
c'est ce que font les mormons met pas
les scientologues si vous achetez un
livre
bon vous vous achetez un livre on essaie
tout ce n'est pas vrai ce que vous dites
moi je donne 35 % mais agents mais
manager j'ai pas besoin de donner un
pourcentage est quelqu'un d'autre est-ce
que la scientologie vous a permis de
vous débarrasser non seulement des des
drogues des toxines
mais vous a permis de de purifier votre
esprit
oui en fait on a bad a découvert un
certain nombre de choses que l'on peut
faire pour se sentir mieux comprendre
par exemple des vitamines ou alors aller
dans un sauna transpiré pour éliminer
les toxines qu'il ya également des cours
sur la communication sur la manière dont
on peut gérer le stress dans certaines
situations il ya des exercices tout
simple pratique et c'est ce que j'ai
fait est ce que vous pensez que la
science beaucoup à hollywood la
scientologie a beaucoup de succès il ya
des acteurs très fameuse lady comme
nicole kidman tom cruise vous qui sont
dans l'église de scientologie est ce que
c'est une façon pour vous de remplacer
les psys de shanks c'est pas grave
j'aime bien ces gars vous comprenez
qu'en france ça nous surprend parce que
l'église de scientologie en france est
considéré comme une secte
enfin bernard oui avec une très mauvaise
réputation on peut le dire donc quand on
voit quelqu'un qui est scientologue
surtout quelqu'un comme vous qui êtes
quelqu'un de qualité on se dit comment
est ce qu'on peut être scientologues
c'est tout on est curieux
pourquoi je suis heureuse que cela ait
posé cette question j'espère arriver à
éclaircir un petit peu les choses pour
vous il ne s'agit pas d'une société
secrète un peu étrange
c'est une philosophie de free qui a aidé
à certaines personnes ne s'agit pas de
se courber on ne parle pas de dieu on ne
vous dit pas ce qu'il faut croire ou ans
qui croit c'est plus c'est plus une
hygiène de vie d'une certaine façon
d'après ce que vous nous dites oui dans
un certain sens l'on ne peut pas
arrivé à se gérer mieux si on prend des
drags donc on n'arrivera pas à s'étaler
lui lire ainsi l'on prend des
médicaments des drogues on essaie
d'échapper à ces problèmes bernard est
ce que vous croyez que pour échapper à
la drogue tout est bon même s'inscrire à
l'église de scientologie ou à l'ump me
crois que non ça ce serait pire
je crois que chaque histoire est une
histoire personnelle telle a
merveilleusement raconter et que c'est
très difficile
et certainement pas en jugeant de
l'extérieur de la comprendre
il est vrai que pour nous l'église de
scientologie est une chose un peu nos
baccino demi non c'est vrai bernard
non c'est vrai que rapport vivien été
terrible oui l'accord oui oui et c'est
bien que nous nous préoccupions de ce
qui nous semble un peu dangereux en
matière de seigle mystère un tout petit
peu maniable et cetera mais ça n'est pas
ce que j'ai entendu de la part de julian
de julienne vous est ce que vous croyez
que pour sortir de la drogue tout est
bon même la scientologie
en tout cas la scientologie en
particulier pour les deux quoi
exactement on peut aller à l'église de
scientologie pour différentes raisons
pas uniquement pour moi et j'ai pas la
drogue et je voudrais ajouter le fait
que les journalistes ne sont pas
toujours honnêtes vous en est conscient
vous savez que les reporter les journaux
ne sont pas toujours honnêtes ils ne
donnent pas toujours les faits il faut
tout remettre en question
mais si on se contente de lire le
journal et puis prendre la vérité de ce
qui est écrit dans les journaux comme la
guerre c'est pareil pour la guerre on
pensait de faire quelque chose de bien
il s'est raidi mal compris tu as menor
juliette ce que je veux dire c'est que
moi je vous jette pas la pierre je ne
critique pas simplement en france ait eu
un rapport d'un député qui s'appelle
robert andré vivien qui est spécialisée
dans les problèmes de sectes et qui a
fait un rapport dans lequel il explique
la scientologie c'est quelque chose de
très dangereux
donc comme vous êtes la première
scientologues que je vois de ma vie je
j'en profite pour vous poser des
questions
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle d'une
religion je vais vous l'expliquer la
scientologie que votre esprit votre
corps vous avez des peurs des craintes
en tant que être spirituel et il faut
essayer de trouver un moyen de gérer
cela et donc tout ce qui a trait à
l'esprit
on dit que c'est du religieux c'est pour
ça qu'on parle d'une religion maintenant
je dirais que c'est plutôt une
philosophie religieuse si vous voulez
une philosophie fin cité sur philosophie
mais c'est reconnu comme une religion
aux etats unis c'est vrai qu'on a une
exigence à l'égard des autres croyances
qu'on n'a pas l'équipe de la nôtre parce
que comme si tu veux regarder la
religion à laquelle nous on est attaché
avec le même oeil critique ou aussi
parce que les produits ayant un croyant
on peut on pas mal à démontrer leur
après la grande différence quand même
c'est que en france il ya un vrai
problème de fric
un vrai problème d'argent c'est à dire
que contrairement aux états unis ou
l'esl et où toutes les religions sont
réelles ont des ailes ont des apôtres
c'est ça fonctionne ou en france pour
tirer de l'argent aux gens le phénomène
religieux et très exploité voilà
justement moi je vois des personnes qui
travaillent dans l'organisation tous les
jours qui est grande les livres ils
n'ont pas de super voiture et non pas
des supers habits ce sont simplement des
jean qui consacrent leur temps et leur
attention aux autres alors vous et cet
argent secret je ne sais pas beaucoup
d'affaires de justice en france avec
l'église de scientologie s'est très très
mal bu il y avait beaucoup de gens qui
ont porté plainte je sais pas comment ça
se passe aux etats unis
mais ici c'est un vrai problème des gens
qui ont été dépossédés de tout ce qu'ils
avaient qui ont signé des papiers qui
ont versé des fortunes à cette église
est ce que vous vous avez ça aux états
unis ou pas du tout je voudrais bien
savoir ce qui s'est passé avec ces
quelques personnes qui portent plainte
ça s'est passé dans leur passé mais bon
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'argent mais bon
disons que bon j'ai de quoi vivre et
personne ne me demande pas ambassadeur
côté juliette merci en tous les cas de
toutes vos explications
avec vincent cassel michael madsen et
juliette lewis qui était notre invité ce
soir
merci
à chaud
hollande
je pense que l'homme
21 heures à l'église de scientologie de
la semaine prochaine a pu nous expliquer
que c'est formidable à sortir de chez
moi j'ai vu tellement de reportage avec
des gens traumatisés à vie et donc j'ai
un petit peu refroidi oui mais oui c'est
vrai et ça tu viens et huawei
bon tu nous remet la musique là je dire
tout le monde voilà merci bernard tapie
merci
chanal merci pascale roberts lui aussi
natif de cognac sera là c'est bernard
dombasle acquiesce c'est pas compliqué
c'est au coeur de paris rue blanche ça
s'appelle un beau [__] c'est assez
drôle vraiment bernard tu restes avec
nous est-ce que matra est la fiancée
karim ziani
merci d'avoir été avec nous bernard
cartes de bons clients vont avoir peur
avant à temps
ouais c'est important parce que des fois
j'ai des ballonnements c'est comme une
colite tu deviens tu ouvert et non mais
pour faire attention on va dire ça alors
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire si on veut
aller à la selle régulièrement mais il
faut prendre quoi comme médicament il
faut avoir une vie saine non l'estomac
c'est comme ça bon bah il est malade
ouais oui c'est un politique tu veux pas
une coloscopie tout le matos et quand tu
veux par où tu veux bernard merci merci
beaucoup
bernard kouchner mais gagner
c'était dit et chez grasset mesdames et
messieurs la salle hubert là
et maintenant
et
[Musique]
qui chante ça c'est olivier andré aco
on y vient veille à caumont soir
et voilà qui croirait que c'est olivia
adriaco c'est très étonnant parce que ça
sonne vraiment anglo saxons alors c'est
un album qui s'appelle ambigüs et le
morceau s'appelle runaway alors oui on
est c'est étonnant parce qu'on vous voit
tous les dimanches à 16 heures 55 sur
tf1 vous présentez vidéo gag en
compagnie de sébastien folin vous
regretté bernard montiel je peux pas
dire je regrette bernard montiel j'ai
passé un très bon moment avec bernard on
s'entendait très bien bon et c'est bien
tard et voilà le sort en a décidé ainsi
simplement bon je m'entends très bien
aussi avec sébastien soi même ton c'est
autre chose
est ce que vous regrettez le chien de
bernard montiel mais si les cv vue ah
ben non il vous a jamais présenté son
chéri nouvelles musiques sont siens est
ce que vous pensez comme bernard montiel
que vidéo gag c'est un moyen super sympa
de se faire platine sont beaucoup bossé
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec ça
parce que d'abord il faut travailler on
a quand même du texte
malgré tout c'est vrai qu'on tourne
beaucoup d'émissions alors est ce que
vous diriez comme bernard montiel que
arthur même avec un prompteur il se
plante c'est un nul le nom mais moi je
dis pas comme bernard montiel vous dirai
pas non plus love story c'est vraiment
débile des [__] des gigolos encore pire
que chez ardisson
non vous diriez pas bernard tapie est un
escroc qui présente une émission naze
banon surtout quand il est parti vous
pourriez venir bien alors montiel ça va
je suis bien vidéo gag bernard était pas
bien c'est pas heureux il sait pas quoi
en soirée thema
est ce que vous diriez comme bernard
montiel que tf1 n'est pas une grande
famille mais je crois qu'aucune chaîne
est une grande famille sera bien fait ça
c'est bien ça de la miel et la vanille
c'est bien est ce que vous diriez comme
bernard montiel que vidéo gag c'est un
peu de la merde vidéo avec de la merde
non c'est impossible que je tiens donc
voilà donc on a détruit pas la planche à
billets non mais de toute façon sinon j
sinon je ne serais pas évidemment
l'avantagé des vidéos gags
évidemment c'est que ça vous laisse le
temps de faire autre chose il faisait
quoi lui quand il faisait pas vidéo gag
mais je crois que il travaillait pour
une grande chaîne d'hôtels quoi donc
aussi donc il voyage beaucoup et vous
faites de la musique moi c'est de la
musique oui votre autre chose à vous
c'est la musique
[Musique]
alors je reçois à l'instant en album de
olivia adriaco je ne savais pas qu'elle
chantait si c'est vrai que j'ai réclamés
à cor et à cri qu'on m'envoie les albums
oui des artistes et j'ai reçu adriaco
alors c'est un début encourageant certes
mais je voudrais recevoir des bons
disques battue c'est pas tant tu l'as
jeu répétitif
à temps
je rectifie je voudrais race avoir
d'autres bons alors l'on écouté le
disent alors alors il est comment il est
comment le mistral alors maintenant du
doyen de la ville tandis la vie mais la
vie elle est plus humaine et imaginatif
que nous parce qu'on m'a volé ce marais
bah écoute ou alors
[Musique]
c'est pas mal écoute alors il ya une
influence blondy non un peu quand même
hein
un peu oui un peu quand les sirènes way
we kiss in aussi c'est vrai vous avez
raison c'est une blonde y passe moins
les 10 est-ce que tu recommanderait
l'achat du disque à un ami laurent un
ami non non alors olivia adriaco l'album
donc s'appelle ambigüs vous avez composé
la moitié des titres l'autre moitié est
composée par cécile maury j'en dirai pas
plus sur cécile marie anne respecter
vraiment ici on respecte la l'intimité
des gens la vie privée c'est une grande
discrétion cette émission cécile maurice
est la personne qui partage red bulls
alors vous allez me olivia trois ans
pour réaliser le disque et toutes vos
économies sont passées dans le
financement de cette production
bah oui oui c'est un prix trois ans
parce que d'abord c'est long de
travailler sur un projet comme cela
apprendre l'anglais il se prête peu de
temps en plus c'est peu live celui qui a
écrit des paroles et paroles est anglais
et donc m'a fait beaucoup travailler
également sur surtout les sont en fin de
compte qui sont allées bien passé et
j'ai même été obligé de monter votre
propre label qui s'appelle ziri corde
nous sortir ce disque alors c'est vrai
quand même olivia bon franchement c'est
pas mal mais vous ai commencé à essayer
de faire de la musique à l'âge de 17 ans
ouais c'est quand même 21 ans
ouais qu'est-ce que pendant toutes ces
années pourquoi seulement dixième
pendant toutes ces années j'ai continué
c'est à dire que à 17 ans j'ai
enregistré mon premier 45 tours parce
qu'à l'époque j'avais pas les céder
donc c'était 40 atos est pas si
longtemps que ça mais c'est comme ça et
donc on sortait des 45 donc j'en ai
sorti 3 après
j'essayais dans une maison de disque
mais ce que je sentais mme ne me
convenait pas j'ai fini par faire des
coeurs travailler avec ma voix jusqu'à
ce que j'arrive à la télévision fin de
compte et quand je suis arrivé à la
télévision j'ai travaillé de façon
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus sereine plus
pur j'ai eu le temps de me poser en fin
de compte sur ce que j'avais envie de de
digérer
il est là ces abris 17 ans c'est quand
même long 17 ans mais il est là
olivier après ce premier album il y en
aura un deuxième puis après il y aura
les concerts et les tournées en france
dans le monde est ce que vous n'avez pas
peur que tf1 le prêt de mal pourquoi je
sais pas parce que vous avez plus vous
intéresser à votre votre métier de
chanteuse de rockeuse plutôt qu'à vidéo
gag dire que ça marche très bien et j'en
serai très fier c'est comme ça c'est pas
grave je suis plus le temps de faire de
la télévision
c'est un bon job comme que vous allez à
tf1 mais bien sûr est ce que pour garder
votre place à tf1
vous accepteriez de dire avec moi
maintenant vidéo gag donne à la
télévision sa dimension culturelle de
proximité
non non non vous ne pouvez pas le dire
ça me donne à la télévision sa dimension
culturelle de proximité ce pas non plus
ces démissions qui se prend pas au
sérieux
et quand j'étais à dire culturel non
bond avec manon mais ce que vous seriez
prête à dire que fontaine et bataille
c'est super je suis pas prête à lui dire
plus que c'est pas bien ou si peu vous
regrettez pas qu'ils aient supprimé
scrupules c'était bien ce que pull
olivia pas eu le temps de voir je prends
est ce que si vous quittiez vidéo gag
devant le succès de votre disque vous
n'avez pas peur que charles villeneuve
reprennent les missions comme il a
repris téléfoot et qu'ils fassent
vidéosurveillance
on veut montrer d'eux
il est bien l'envers aussi lui si
l'express m alors olivier en 2001 sur
rire et chansons ouais vous ai présenté
une émission qui s'appelait trop blonde
pour moi donc ça vous pend au nez je me
fais rire et faire rire n'est qu'en tant
que blonde
[Musique]
alors olivier en tant que blonde quels
ont été les quatre années les plus dures
de votre vie bah ma classe de sixième
pourquoi parlez vous jamais quand vous
faites l'amour je sais pas on m'a
toujours dit qu'il fallait pas parler
aux étrangers chance en tant que blonde
comment pourrais-je vous pour mac de
m'épouser avec une pause bisous
santé
m
non tu as remarqué que je chope
aujourd'hui mais grave
tammy la langue avec tapis tapis jamais
la langue bien que kouchner qu'a refusé
pas le premier soir les fidèles sur
gastro en tant que blonde
que répondez vous quand on vous demande
si votre clignotant marche ne connais en
tant que blonde
que faites-vous pour éviter les
contraventions voilà j'espère la blonde
intelligente je vais enlever visite
ligne bravo en tant que blonde comment
faites-vous pour tuer un poisson le noir
à l école et barker c'est parfait en
tant que blonde pourquoi voulez vous
toujours être assise à côté du boulot
dans un avion c'est juste pour prendre
un peu d'air en tant que blonde pourquoi
prenez-vous la pilule pour me rappeler
jours qu'on est contre luçon
connais par coeur le disque l'eau
caméra d'or
bref c'est avec nous à les saisir en
tant que blonde en tant que blanc way
à
non
c'est quoi votre parfois c'est son bon
gars là ça va aussi bien vrai ça je
conçois pas tous les deux bah on est
tous les trois lots
ça
voici ma psy
salut qu'à 6 comment ça va très bien
toujours très bien sapés c'est vraiment
un sapeur celui la lecture d'une
élégance total va vous connaissez pas si
olivia non à y gagner deux connu c'est
un type formidable super swede super
doux comment ça va la petite famille du
rap ça va ça va bien ça se passe doc
gynéco
il va bien ouais je te met aussitôt mis
sur les stars ça va bien ça va bien un
coup de shell tout le monde va bien
akhenaton ça va ça va même si jean gabin
il va bien aussi même si cela est il en
train de faire des nouveaux clips nouvel
ami laurent gerra ça va alors ça marche
pour vous un lan ont en commun ce we à
la salle damrémont bien la balle hors
depuis que vous êtes riche ça vous monte
pas les contrôles de police mme
l'intérieur me conte soirée chopard et
joue qu'on soit dans le quartier par
quartier on a tout le temps des
contrôles de police richard arish quoi
ouais ouais et discutés dans les halls
d'immeuble ça vous monte pas non non
parce que bon jeu on s'est toujours dit
dans les halls d'immeuble qu'il faudrait
qu'on bouge qu'il faudrait qu'on aille
voir ailleurs ce qui se passe donc j'ai
eu l'occasion de faire avec la musique
et voilà je vais au bout de mes rêves et
et faire parler sarcelles à pied quand
on a raté le dernier train ça vous
manque pas dans un sens ça monte ça
s'ajoute france d'épée galère c'était
galère et les meufs qui vous jette ça
vous manque pas maintenant que vous êtes
riche
or il ya toujours le marais temps te
connais tu es connu mais non mais ça va
je veux banquiers comme le banquier
relou ça vous manque pas maintenant vous
êtes le départ ouais il ya toujours une
période sa rechute ou commence à
chipoter
voilà faut travailler alors ça marche le
22 mars va sortir un album qui s'appelle
odyssée et en attendant il ya un premier
single qui s'appelle reviens dans ma vie
[Musique]
pas si il revient dans ma vie dont s'est
extrait d'un album à sortir au mois de
mars qui s'appelle odyssée et depuis le
26 janvier un dvd qui s'appelle 30 ans
chrono et qui racontent pas si votre vie
et votre carrière
l'histoire de toutes vos chansons dit du
[Musique]
canal
quelle affaire 19 ans je suis avec quand
même une flatteuse
quand je me lève mon jogging jeudi matin
bonheur marié deux enfants faire du
télé-shopping l'achat pour les jours te
répète et le match auront qu on est
enfermé seul moyen de votre part on part
bloqués et bloqué lui dans l'oeil et
le bruit des clés
se répète et le map
[Musique]
salle
deux cas les hommes c'est que sur le
moment la corde ayrault au virage est
pas sûr qu est trop
le broco les sons et les mots à nous
donner vos combos libéré
l'acide gamma mines délai pour lâche pas
le contrôle célian sait rien on l'a dit
c'est redonner la haine de la meute
moi je
[Musique]
hier
chez toi et moi
arleux
[Musique]
pardon
toi mais au fait
il
voici donc c'est tout
c'est toute votre carrière et l'histoire
de ces chansons qui a raconté dans ce
dvd qui s'appelle 30 ans chrono pas si
je suis dans le dvd - thierry ardisson
parce qu'à un moment on a eu un problème
ensemble à l'époque de ministère amer il
a fait une chanson qui s'appelait
sacrifice de poulet et à l'époque je
dirigeais le journal entrevues et donc
j'avais interviewé ministère amer on
s'est retrouvé au tribunal tous ensemble
à noter un bad boy et puis ya aussi
l'histoire de émeutes avec un sample de
charles aznavour comme extraordinaire
via l'on sait désormais où elle était
très très très cool sur sur
l'autorisation
donc chaque fois je les remercie je le
remercie encore aujourd'hui c'était mon
jour
ouais là peut être chercher pour te
bourrer la gueule il ya aussi sur
émeutes les choeurs de l'armée rouge
assez étonnant 1 119 jours avec les
choeurs de l'armée rouge voilà ils
doivent de prod qui s'appelle i sapin il
ya divers de zouk qui est un tube énorme
qu'on vient d'entendre j'ai pris
beaucoup de pognon à leur nom n'est pas
ça y est on est les opérations comme
dealer de zokou bissau c'est pas le mec
les solos on a toujours beaucoup et
alors il ya trop de gens là voilà c'est
ça le problème
mais bon faut faire avec voilà et alors
ce qu'on voit aussi dans le dvd c'est
que on vous voit travailler avec robbie
des platters qui étaient en studio avec
vous et c'est génial de revoir avec des
platters est un vrai respect pour un
grand respect en plus qu'engagé vient à
côté de toi et chantons liu
cette vis à vis sont tous deux exercices
exalte club des crèmes dans cet accident
s'est passé en studio et croire obligé
platters quand même hein c'est pareil ah
ben là vous l'avez retrouvé comme en
basse et c'est une fille qui était sur
10 l'heure 2 zouk qui s'appelle gerica
il chante aux trois maillets qui est un
petit un petit cabaret à saint michel
qui m'a invité et puis il était là ce
jour là il donnait aussi un spectacle
est tout de suite gelés dès que j'ai vu
dès qu'il a entendu chanter j'étais
loire j'ai dit tu es en studio et on a
calé ça et ça c'est fait j'ai été très
bonne expérience
alors voilà donc revient dans ma vie
s'est extrait de 10 et qui sort le 22
mars il ya le dvd donc 30 ans chrono qui
raconte toute votre vie s'écoule ouais
enfin cgg j'ai toujours voulu capturer
tous les événements en images
et là j'avais beaucoup d'image avaient
beaucoup d'heures de rush et j'avais de
quoi faire ce dvd
donc il ya le côté réal qui m'attire
beaucoup
et donc je me suis amusé avec mes amis
un monteur on a passé quelques mois à
bosser ça c'était pas mal merci
voici trente ans chrono le dvd qui
raconte sa vie et sa carrière
[Musique]
et maintenant
j christophe alévêque
merci comment ça va bien
ouais mieux ce serait pire voit mieux ça
serait pire
je connaissais laurent baffie oui vous
aimez bien tous les deux oui vous
appréciez oui c'est pas bien il faut
détester les gens n'ont pas du tout
pourquoi je suis pas content tu as l'air
étonné non non non mais ce que je sais
la les comics entre eux ils ce n'est pas
très drôle
et voilà c'est la loi du genre c'est
laurent baffie voilà donc christophe
alévêque star de one man show et puis
aussi tourner à tout essayer
l'émission présentée par laurent ruquier
vous réaliser un vieux rêve vous aussi
c'est un petit peu comme il viendrait à
co 17 ans qu'elle voulait nous faire
sans renouer et vous vous chanter ça y
est vous avez un groupe rival christophe
alévêque et son groupe oh oui nous avons
nous avons fait ça on a commencé il ya
un an au mois de juin dans un vieux qui
est superbe à la cave à musique comme un
conte ans très connu des équipes
préparent les émissions laurence
incroyable et musiciens c'est
et puis ma foi ça suit son bonhomme de
chemin sans ça bien bien tourner sur
scène est ma foi ont continué moi
j'avais envie de faire ça depuis vos si
oui alors avant d'être perclus par les
rhumatismes l'arthrose je me suis dit il
faut que je le fasse parce que sinon
alors voilà donc christophe alévêque
paul eluard et son groupe os et tous les
premiers lundis du froid à la scène la
scène bastille web rue des taillandiers
dans le 11e très belle salle à la
rousseur ben voilà
[Musique]
c'est par là
et les 1
en portant
informés
non ça
christophe alévêque et son groupe ont à
la scène tous les premiers lundis du
quoi donc rue des taillandiers dans le
11e quel pied
je m'imaginais que ça va être le pied
mais à ce point
à vous raconter quoi s'est présenté une
chanson qui s'appelle ya ce qu'on dit il
ya ce qu'on pense ça parle de quoi
est ce qu'on dit est ce qu'on pense il
récompense il ya ce qu'on dit à ce qu'on
dit qu'on pense et il ya ce qu'on pense
qu'on a 10 mai à ce qu'on dit ça ce
qu'on pense tous compenser tout ce qu'on
dit car si on dit pas tout ce qu'on
pense on pensait pas ça mais c'est odile
à pointer bondage une chanson sur quoi
je voulais écrire une chanson sur la
solitude les gens qui cherchent à
exister
et j'étais parti sur un truc petit peu
prise de tête et finalement on a trouvé
un bon refrain c'est des gens qui
cherchent à exister il y en a beaucoup
dans notre société et on a pensé à
l'idée d'un mec qui qui qui pensent que
sa [__] parle et qui dit qui dit ça aux
gens comme ça je ne suis pas superman je
ne suis pas un héros je ne suis pas iron
man mais ma [__] parle et c'est une
chanson contre la solide duel chanson il
y en a marre ça parle de quoi ça parle
de la société dans laquelle on vit à
zoug ou du gland tisme de l'apathie et
consensualiste nom de tout ce monde où
le savoir de quoi ça parle de mon doudou
c'est quoi ton doudou
bah c'est le sait tous qu'on s'imaginait
quand on était petit
tout allait bien dans la poussette maman
était là on lui téter le sein alors que
maintenant pour toucher 1 5 là c'est
vachement dur et c'est tout ça donc
c'est un peu ces rendez moi mon de dour
mettez moi dans la poussette à l'abri
des tempêtes là où c'est chaud là où
c'est doux c'est bien le crucifix c'est
une chanson sur la religion catholique
oui oui le crucifix c'est un sursaut qui
n'est pas de moitié de patrick fonte
ouais c'est une chanson tout simplement
que c'est quelqu'un qui s'imaginent
qu'ils aimeraient bien être à la place
de 2,2 du crucifix qui après un
difficile accord d'accord voilà que ce
crucifix qui redit moi comment elle va à
patrick fonde parce qu'il nous a
brutalement quitté quelques années elle
écoute ça va moi je les régulièrement
outre iphone il essaye de se réinsérer
comme font beaucoup de gens qui ont vécu
la prison alors christophe saison après
saison votre succès se confirme sans que
vous renier réellement votre moi profond
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai connu il ya
quelques années vous avez jamais changé
de ligne
vous serez peut-être bientôt dans la
liste des 50 français préférés des
français
après quelques efforts oui pourquoi pas
lui arriver un autre monde et bill c'est
triste ouais on va voir si vous pouvez
rentrer dans cette liste en fait
remonter le top 50 est ce que pour
entrer dans la liste des 50 français
préférés des français
vous seriez prêt comme david douillet à
passer vos journées avec bernadette
chirac écoute pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
si je suis sûr que
une canicule l'été prochain est ce que
pour entrer dans ce cas est-ce que
chirac qui font chier à chaque fois il a
arrêté du v comme ça ça me savais que si
tu à chaque fois est ce que pour entrer
dans cette liste des 50 français
préférés des français
vous seriez prêt à perdre vos cheveux
comme zinedine zidane se sont au prix où
il est payé moi je crois que je perdre
la tête à dakar est ce que pour entrer
dans cette liste vous seriez prêt comme
henri salvador arrière toutes les 4
secondes
non est ce que vous pourriez faire comme
dans l'art kouchner quitté là il ya un
instant à votre place à vivre avec
christine ockrent
oui pourquoi pas elle gagne bien l e
mais si il restera kouchner est ce que
vous seriez prêt que ce qui me plaît
bien
pour entrer dans cette liste est ce que
vous seriez prêt comme florent pagny à
ne plus payer vos impôts que je serai
prêt à faire rien comme florent pagny
suis d'accord voilà car une écharpe
autour du cou n'en est rien les lunettes
le bras marchante et puisque je me suis
mis mais non moi je suis pour qu'on paye
ses impôts
je suis même content d'en payer enfin à
part évidemment quand je découvre la
somme sur le moment ça fait un choc
jamais plaisir mais vous dites cela
quelque chose mais évidemment ça on
construit des porte avions tout ça bien
sûr cette lotion utile est ce que vous
seriez prêt pour entrer dans cette liste
à faire comme nicolas hulot c'est à dire
à devenir ami avec une loutre c'est fait
je suis mariée depuis les stocks et son
groupe au téléphone
du mois à l'as
détaillant
c'est dans l'ancienne bellamy
et maintenant ici
[Musique]
mais si je t'ai vannes rousseau
les fans au saumon soir pierre dit
sombrons soit la main très bien vous
aussi alors je m'étais on broadway parce
que vous reprenez un paris chicago qui a
été un des grands succès de broadway
vous faites tout d'abord humoriste je
suis devenu humoriste parce que ma mère
me trouvais très drôle et c'est vrai que
vous savez tout faire vous savez chanter
danser jouer la comédie on l'a vu encore
récemment dans le film de denys arcand
qui s'appelle les invasions barbares qui
était la suite de la chute de l'empiré
américain qu'est un film extraordinaire
que je conseille à tous nos amis vous
étiez assez touchant dans le film
peut-être parce que vous avez vécu dans
votre vie des événements qui se
rapprochent de ceux du film non ouais je
dois dire que le sujet me touche et un
peu trouve c'est l'histoire d'un type
qui meurent du cancer
ouais et vous vos parents ont souffert
du cancer voilà les deux ans sont
décédés malheureusement donc je crois
que la mort de ma mère m'avait
probablement préparé
c'est un peu con mais a tourné ce film
il ya vingt ans que ma mère est décédée
mais j'ai tourné le film et puis j'ai
perdu malheureusement mon père six mois
après alors le film comme peut-être
préparer ou aussi ou des saignements il
a vu le film votre père oui oui la vie
trois fois des as un film exceptionnel
vraiment un grand grand film alors vous
avez plein de qualités c'est clair on
vient de le voir mais est ce que vous
pourriez arrêter cet accent à la con non
mais c'est comme ça c'est l'épouvantail
ya de quoi jeter patron vous adore
vraiment vous êtes mignon vous est
talentueux mais au bout de combien de
temps quand on est à paris on se rend
compte qu'on a cet accent m'écoute je me
permets de vous tutoyer tu veux tu peux
t'envoyer cette femme ok non mais tu
sais que ça fait des vagues au québec
dadis un moment donné une fille qui
avait écrit le livre [__] qui était
venu tout à fait écoute tout le monde en
a parlé parce que il ya dit que notre
accent était c'est épouvantable et tout
le monde parlait des tirs est absent
mais c'est une façon de vous faire
connaître
bah oui finalement mais est ce qu a dit
devant les émeutes sk des grossesses qui
tourne dit non déjà à cause de cet
accent vraiment pas à vraiment pas mal
isabelle boulay l'htap a quitté à cause
de ton accent non non c'est pour
d'autres raisons
mais c'est vrai quand je disais que vous
saviez tout faire stéphane c'est vrai
que vous revenez donc à partir du 13
février sur la scène du casino de paris
dans la célèbre comédie musicale chicago
alors on va voir à quoi ça ressemble en
version anglaise parce que dans la
version française on l'a pas encore
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
mike batt
[Musique]
wen à chicago à partir du 13 février sur
la scène du casino de paris alors ça
donc la version américaine et
d'adaptation française a été faite par
notre ami laurent rouyer
voilà alors peu de grands copains voilà
mon grand ami bien sûr alors la
meilleure façon de présenter chicago
c'est pas la peine de faire des pitchs
et mâcha c'est que c'est une comédie
musicale qui a été jouée plus de dix
mille fois qu'ils chantent
oui plus de six mois dans le monde
elle a été vue par 12 millions de
spectateurs dans plus de 16 pays et elle
a importé 550 millions de dollars à
travers le monde
voilà la vraie raison d'y aller c'est ça
à dire qu'une pièce qui a eu autant de
succès dans le monde entier
ça peut pas être mal hein non vraiment
moi je suis pas j'ai jamais été un
amateur tellement de comédie musicale
et puis on m'avait approché dans le
passé pour d'autres comédies puis ça me
disais pas mais quand j'ai vu celle là
c'est vraiment différent parce que il ya
une histoire vraiment palpitante c'est
un constat aussi de sur les américains
c'est une belle image un peu dur des
américains mais ça vaut vraiment le coup
les performances le rythme de ce
spectacle d'un la rigueur américaine
derrière soi on est coachée par les gens
de renouer alors au canada c'était
anthony kavanagh oui et en france pour
elle n'a pas repris parce que les gens
voudraient pas d'un noir dans le rôle
vous pensé non non non pas du tout c'est
un choix personnel c'est lui que dès le
départ il y avait décidé de faire
seulement le spectacle au québec parce
qu'ils travaillent sur une autre projet
ici alors ils pouvaient pas ne pouvait
pas le faire ici bien écoutez maintenant
on va s'y coller on va faire une
interview en québécois
alors comment tu vas tu as pas prête
asteur non non j'ai pas trop au fret mon
et fred cet hiver il fait moins 50 chez
nous dis moi tu sais que tu as les yeux
dans la graisse de bines et et mettez
pas mal bon quand même
des hot team trois pointes et comment ça
serait allégée comment ça se fait que tu
as les yeux dans la graisse de bines
belle aux cheveux fatigués un chat je
suis fatigué c'est le décalage
tu t'es brossé à la brousse à la boue
est une expression québécois s'est
brossé un labo est appelé une brosse à
la brousse et à picoler la bière voilà
depuis août à paris tu as pris ta pris
une marche ou pas en tout huit jours de
travail pour les
c'est une langue j'apprends tellement
non j'ai pris une marche ce matin je me
suis levé très tôt ce matin 6h30 je me
baladais à montmartre un tat magazine et
outils taponier le cul non je me suis
les magasins étaient fermés ces jeunes
au sol j'étais seul malheureusement et
10 mois avec ce tabernacle de parisienne
tafer des becs d'un passé way vient de
passer dans le passé elles ont des
belles foules non au jeu suit comprise
non mais je sais qu'il a fournis chez
vous c'est pas la même fougue que chez
nous voilà dix mois depuis que tu es à
paris la revenue la tâche ce qu'est un
peu d'épis non j'ai revu sur les trois
jours j'ai pas eu tant de fautes chaque
fois qu'ils ont dit pas ça c'est
américaine à bord qui nous dit et
heureusement que tu as pris tes gosses
avec toi ouais ouais ouais
voici les couilles
merci d'avoir jaser tu veux un suçon way
se sent chez vous c'est un bad beat
mais ce sens je sais nous c'est une
sucette
c'est le contraire en fait c'était
l'intérieur aux québécois ça supporte
[Musique]
et non
voici s'il boutemane
soir
sabah cyril très bien depuis tant
d'années depuis tant d'années qu'on
s'est vus oui alors vous allez 41 ans
vous êtes fils de l'éditeur d'art
jacques putman entre autres protecteurs
de bram van velde et de la décoratrice
andrée putman que tout le monde connaît
qui est mondialement connu voilà vous
êtes agent d'artistes est désormais
écrivain puisque vous publié chez robert
laffont
un livre qui s'appelle première pression
à froid sous titrée pur produit pinc
voilà alors c'est une autobiographie
d'un des premiers punks français moi
j'étais témoin vous étiez effectivement
l'un des premiers vins français en 70 à
dire une photo dans libération qu'il
atteste donc vous aviez 15 ans à cette
époque à et et c'est là qu'on s'est
connu d'ailleurs en 77 voix alors vous
raconter votre vie vous raconter votre
expérience que sont devenus les parcs
parce qu'évidemment les mecs qui n'avait
no future qu'est ce qu'ils sont devenus
qu'elle a essayé mort reste presque en
grande barre dit qu'elle a été le futur
des no futur voilà la question parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de casse beaucoup
beaucoup de casse et vous vous n'êtes
pas passés loin de deux lacs de la caso
si oui on est heureux de vous voir
alors vous raconter votre vie votre vie
de famille alors au début ça commence
très bien c'est une ancienne usine
immense rue des grands augustins à paris
avec un appartement qui se raccorde à
lui l usine désaffectée donc c'est vrai
que tout ça est assez était assez
grandiose des amis de vos parents
setting lycées niki de saint phalle
célestine ski et puis la rue aussi parce
que c'est vrai que vous jouez dans la
rue devant chez vous avec les avec les
voisins voilà alors ça c'est une époque
donc sur la très bien vous avec vos
parents rue des grands augustins famille
bourgeoise branché dans l'art etc
et puis vous brancher mon cher cyril sur
la face obscure du rock'n'roll
c'est à dire à 9 ans il va voir les
stones au palais des sports
évidemment dans les stones ce qu'il
préfère c'est sympathy for the devil tu
vois c'est à dire tout de suite il est
très attiré quand même ma part le côté
noir de cette musique
et quand le pain qui arrive vous adhérez
immédiatement à 7
cette philosophie du new futur ou
devenait complètement destroy et vos
idoles là c'est plus les stones c'est
les sex pistols et encore mieux
les clashs voilà tout tout à fait alors
là vous avez les cheveux bleus moi je
m'en souviens
maintenant et rouge et rouge bleu un
voyage à londres vous permet d'acheter
le fameux blouson streep et les voilà
les jambes sangle est le pantalon de
viviane westwood qui avait pas mal
marqué à l'époque l'hôpital allemand et
ses sangles et oui la panoplie du pain
voilà était devenu parrain complètement
et alors le style de vie c'est-à-dire la
bière beaucoup beaucoup de bière de
laval star verte aller alors tout à fait
le frein ganor losc était à d'autres
fins que je conseille à personne et
s'est toujours se limer les dents parce
que si on a des grandes dents de lapin
safran ganor ça je vais te dire je crois
qu'ils en jeu je crois que le frein je
crois que le championnat ça a été
supprimé ah bon oui je pense que ça a
été supprimée parce que les autorités
médicales se sont aperçus que c'était
plus un dandy c'était plus de
l'endomètre farrell balle et le bon goût
le principe du pogo vous le savez on
saute on saute sur place en essayant de
cracher sur ses amis c'est un bleu sa
psp dans le showbiz
ouais c'est ça oui bien sûr que des
bouteilles de verre avant par terre un
petit tapis pour recycler en quelqu'un
tomberait alors elle alors si rim s'il
était vraiment le pain que type on peut
le dire un très disciplinés au fessier
tout ce qu'il fallait faire pour être un
vrai punk et la consécration est arrivé
lorsque cyril putman a été interviewé
par alain pacadis dans libération
évidemment ça a été une espèce de
d'apothéose est il alors ce qui est
extraordinaire sédition c'est qu'au
départ le pain que c'est une réaction
contre les babas contre les babas
planant qui prenaient des pétards qui
avait les cheveux longs qui étaient
habillés avec des chemises indienne qui
écoute et calme voilà c'est ça c'est ici
d'un truc contre l'hérault contre
laplane reekoye qu'est-ce qui est très
bizarre c'est que les pins qui au départ
était en réaction contre ça finalement
on sombrait dedans sombré corps et âme
dans la dope est grave
en tous les cas en ce qui vous concerne
voilà alors ce qui est très bizarre
c'est que c'est des amis de votre mère
qui vous en fais prendre votre première
ligne d'héroïne
voilà tout est fait ça s'est fait un peu
par hasard j'ai été cueilli un peu à
froid c'est bien quel âge cyril j'avais
15 ans et donc cette fête on ma
donné on mate fait hara et dayraut et on
a été même un peu plus loin c'est ce qui
est assez sérieuse et qu'on m'a donnée
en même temps 3 grammes ce qui fait que
ça m'a permis d'être bien accro bout de
dix quinze jours ce qui fait que j'ai
été tout de suite c'était des vrais amis
de votre mère well et si je puis dire
oui si on peut dire est ce que vous les
avez revu depuis
à vrai dire ils sont morts les deux donc
ils s'en sortent bien d'une morale quand
le moral dans la vie quand on vous dit
ça a été sublime
évidemment si c'était infecte ça se
saurait et le problème serait réglé
voilà c'est vrai que séguéla et sa pub
en dix ans la drogue c'est de la merde
jamais vu personne a acheté 12 s'emballe
un gramme de merde et qu' il faut dire
que la drogue c'est de la merde mais
mais pas tout de suite c'est après alors
le leak effectivement c'est que donc il
vous donne ses 3 g et puis quand le
paquet est finie et ben vous êtes en
manque vous découvrez le manque
voilà le les reins commencent à bloquer
un peu et là ça devient en fait l enfer
alors ce qui est très bizarre avec le
monde sait qu'à l'époque où quand on
parlait du monde personnes comprenait et
puis maintenant tous les français
essaient d'arrêter de fumer pas tous à
beaucoup et quand j'ai vu à la télé une
pub tout à l'heure ah bah oui quand vous
sent tellement que mettez vous un patch
c'est à dire que ce moment qui était
réservé aux vrais gros et bien entendu
est devenu complètement popularisé
maintenant les gens sont en manque de
nicotine comme vous avez été donc à ce
moment-là en manque d'héroïne alors mal
au dôme alors un moral à zéro vous
découvrez ce que c'est d'être accro aux
sacs au départ comme j'ai dis tout le
temps on en prend pour être bien et puis
après on en prend pour pas être mal et
donc vous essayer d'en trouver pour pas
être mal sa peau est normal qu'un point
de l'hérault c'est qu'à prendre on prend
juste pour être normal sinon ça sert
plus à rien voilà c'est pour ça que très
souvent les parents de deux jeunes
trouvent que leurs enfants ont l'air en
super forme quand ils sont défoncés il
les trouve assez pâlichon quand ils sont
en entrée parce que ils comprennent pas
alors votre père justement c'est
l'attitude des parents 68 c'est terrible
à dire mais enfin c'est vrai comment
c'est terrible à dire mais c'est vrai
c'est vrai que votre père il vous filmer
le bal par jour il demande même pas où
est ce que vous cramer ce pognon en quoi
c'est pas pour nommer de marque mais il
n'y avait pas de y avait pas de voitures
de sport allemande décapotable dans la
cour c'est un mètre 93 je faisais 52 kg
donc ouais y avait quand même un
problème quoi donc le père lui vous
filmer le bal sans demander où ça va et
votre mère andrée basse moment là est
très préoccupée par sa survie aussi et
tout vous laisse un petit peu voilé à
aller à vau l'eau
et ça c'est un truc qu'on peut dire aux
parents qui nous regarde parce que il
faut quand même surveiller quoi c'est
vrai qu'un môme qui prend un gran d
euros tous les deux jours ça peut se
voir bout d'un moment juste marrant
c'est que vous n'avez jamais fumé des
joints
non vous êtes directement dans l'héroïne
êtes passés directement on dit souvent
les drogues douces amène aux drogues
dures vous êtes passé directement de
rigueur tout à fait voilà mêlée et on
amène pas forcément un gros merci aussi
à tous les cas vous dites j'ai eu comme
destin l'héroïne comme d'autres ont
comme destin de star écrasé par un bus
il faisait comme si j'avais été cueilli
un peu à froid sens d'une volonté
farouche
1 j'ai pas été et réal fab et city pour
en trouver quoi c'est arrivé à la maison
dans une soirée livrés à domicile ça
vous est déjà arrivé ça stéphane non non
j'ai pas eu cette chance moi tant mieux
pour vous tatoueur qui est venu chez toi
c'est un ami de ses parents qui étaient
là tout s'est tu veux chacun sait trés
vous pas si ça vous est arrivé ça non
non j'ai on a toujours fui ce pays
devrait contrôler un titre a concédé
face à va il ya prescription
on avait beaucoup de gens tomber ouais
tombé à avoir des mauvaises et enfin
sortir d'une bonne situation 1 et se
retrouver au plus bas que terre avec ça
donc ça nous a toujours fait peur alors
voilà alors la série le pouls condamne à
lorient le mans des mois j'ai fait j'en
reçois pas détrompe toi pourquoi tu
crois je me suis lancée dans la musique
pour tirer sur tout ce qui bouge une
droguée et voilà donc là c'est
l'apothéose vous partez à londres avec
le fameux alain pacadis quinze jours
sans manger sans dormir
comment vous avez un rétrécissement de
l'estomac c'est un moment encore m
à un moment vous mangez un petit morceau
de pain brioché vous avez l'impression
de bouffer un oursin quoi voilà alors
bon je passe les galères ça a été ça est
épouvantable et un jour vous avec votre
mère aux états unis et vous allez voir
si ce virus
d comme je l'avais rencontré side à
londres à l'époque de en soit ce mal à
l'époque de mclaren quand ma mère a
voulu m'emmener à new york
quand j'avais 15 ans je lui ai dit moi
je veux bien y aller mais à la condition
c'est qu'on aille voir s'il en prison
comme j'étais mineure il y avait eu que
ma mère ma compagne au pénitencier et au
pénitencier américain
si vous venez voir rien c'est que déjà
vous même pas très très bien
on est un petit pépin dès qu'on rentre
et en civil suscité au pénitencier parce
qu'il avait tué sa petite amie donc la
gta le chelsea dans le célèbre dans la
légende noire du rock'n'roll et là quand
vous le voyez quand même c'est ce vrai
dayraut plus de déguisements vous dites
dans votre bouquin no more chaud ouais
c'est le petit oiseau mouillé c'est
l'arrogance a disparu il dans sa petite
tenue orange avec les gens va tâcher et
tout et on se parle par téléphone il ya
une vitre c'est vrai que c'était - the
great rock'n'roll swindle c'est clair
c'est clair il est mou en costume
maintenant il est temps il est mort
d'une overdose quelques jours avant son
procès sylvie cious sa mère qui était à
moitié folle et à moitié zhang
dès que les dés que malcom mclaren a
payé la caution
pourrait faire sortir le lendemain sa
mère lui a trouvé un plan voix
semblablement d'assez bonnes vu qu'il
est mort deux heures après comme sein de
la grande famille là bas vous raconter
toute l'histoire quoi les dealers le
rapport sado maso avec l'édile alors
qu'ils vous font attendre vous allez
chez eux puis vouloir parler de leur
famille parce que mais qui tarde pas
même à sortir le petit paquet le ticket
pas et donc vous êtes là on va vous
raconter tout ça très bien il ya une
anecdote qui est très vrai près votre
bouquin est très vrai vous dites que
vous éventré les pailles avec un cutter
après huit jours d'utilisation pour
récupérer le dépôt d'une semaine de
consommation tout ça c'est très c'est un
truc de théâtre est assez parlante c'est
parce qu'ils connaissent malheureusement
voilà vous raconter comment l'hérault
vous prendre la tête toute la journée
commença devient travail à temps complet
calcium full time job ouais c'est ça
ouais staff du matin au soir vous
cherchez vous trouvez vous prenez vous
chers jeunes se trouvent les trouver le
plan ainsi de suite
voilà alors vous auriez pu y rester et
vous raconter comment un jour devant un
hôtel à bangkok il ya un mec qui vend
des souvenirs avec marc est un éloge
bangkok un petit 1 petite taille et qui
vous dit c'est vrai en même temps et bus
stop pourquoi tu fais ça quoi tu étais
pas vu me dit c'est un hymne dit une
phrase très bizarre il me dit c'est pas
pour toi hein alors qu'on est à bangkok
en face d'un de tel de junk assez aigu
que lui il a sa mini
sa mini échoppes qui est là et je vais
le voir comme ça pour parler avec lui
puis au bout de deux jours on commence
un peu à sympathiser il me dit tu sais
moi des blancs qui finissent 25 ans dans
les geôles thaïlandaises j'en ai vu
partir beaucoup c'est pas pour toi mais
par contre je connais une pilule magique
parce que
je sais absolument pas ce que c'était il
se trouve que c'était de la méthadone la
fameuse méthodes et c'était très en
avance de la surêté donne en france et
donc c'est comme ça grâce à la méthadone
grâce à ce petit vendeur de souvenirs à
bangkok vous découvrez la méthadone et
puis après vous vous arrangez votre
affaire vous faites vous vos posologie
vous même pour vous en sortirez vous
vous en êtes sortis mais la sphère a
quand même duré douze ans mais ça c'est
12 ans dans l'hérault c'est long c'est
assez long très très long
c'est très très bien parce que c'est
très très con donc les choses très très
con guignard 12 ans est forcément très
très long vous vous dites ce qui ne vous
tue pas vous rend plus fort c'est vrai
ouais c'est la fameuse phrase de niches
va quand même temps il vaut mieux pas
passer par là sur plus viscéral c'est
parce qu'on doit dire aux enfants pour
démarrer le 10 la conversation en
musique les jeunes et les adultes qui
vous disais que c'était pas bien qu'elle
ait pas en prendre ça vous a pas empêché
de même temps les héros de ces années là
n'était pas du tout l'hérault
d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire que c'était
l'hérault était beaucoup plus chic
c'était avait un côté opium des années
20 voilà tout à fait la prudence c'était
que de la taille blanche labro lebron ça
a été un choc quand même donné quoi ziro
janvier qui seraient tentés par sa basse
et on répète fatalement mêmes conneries
il faut les respecter parce qu'un encore
envie d'en prendre
il faut l'hérault c'est vraiment
l'horreur quoi c'est un cauchemar on a
quand même tous été témoins de plein
d'amis 1 qui sont plus là pour nous
raconter ça donc
et puis je pense que ça correspond plus
du tout à l'époque dans lequel on vit à
un côté complètement out quoi dans
l'hérault il ya un truc pas tes bons
arguments c'est à dire que c'est plus
branché voilà peut-être dépassé il ya
des trucs mieux maintenant
un vrai quand tu vois là là il ya quand
même une traîtrise à ce niveau là tout
tout les pop stars qui ceux qui s'en
remettaient plat le corner quand on
revoit david bowie maintenant qui fait
de la pub pour vittel pour pisser tu
vois ça fait un peu alors moi justement
j'ai essayé de ne pas tomber dans le
truc qui passe de l'extrême de l'hérault
à la soupe aux poireaux yoga parce que
c'est une autre forme j'ai aussi grave
végétarienne et ces mêmes principes
j'étais arrêté obtenir en temps avec un
bon bordeaux
voilà très bien on est heureux de vous
voir si elle
c'est ce rapport
madame alexa
il ya des trous des bungalows et tafer
boucher les trous
non non non non non c'est qu'on donne ça
cicatrise quoi s'attirer ça veut dire
qu'on sait bien qu'on s'en remet à dieu
mais devant mouchel et à l'eau ça veut
dire quoi web où je trouve ça c'est
quelqu'un qui baisse et quand il t'offre
ta place ainsi un bouche trou qui fait
des imitations thierry ouais donc
demander régulièrement une imitation ah
oui mais si félicitations mais j'en fais
plus vraiment mais à beaune imitateur
tue ses limites et qui par exemple tom
jones entre eux tu sait imiter tom joad
et tu me l'a pas dit mais je sais
j'étais pas tout dit encore tu sais
faire she's à lady au oui je pleurais
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour que les
deux faces on n'a pas cherché un câble
chèque
merci christophe si aucune barre
les bains
voilà c'est guthmann
mission
mais ce travail
merci d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoup
qu'est ce qui s'est passé non je deviens
une carte de bons clients ouais ils
faisaient comme ça
et maintenance à venir
[Musique]
ouais si julie le bar dieu et yann moix
julie depardieu yann moix bonsoir à tous
les deux vous êtes ici évidemment pour
podium inutile de le cacher plus
longtemps
film de yann moix avec julie depardieu
jean paul rouve et benoît poelvoorde
le pitch or là vous allez le faire
puisque vous avez fait le bouquin et le
vivre ça je peux pas le faire le pitch
c'est l'histoire d'un sosie de claude
françois qui a raccroché
ouais et un de ses meilleurs amis venant
voir une grande cérémonie des saisies
organisé par evelyne thomas le pousse à
recommencer à retomber dans son vice qui
cote françois au grand dam de sa femme
interprétée par juillet par lieu voilà
et son métier c'est claude françois et
claire une décision qui tombe c'est
bernard frédéric l'apprendre à me
connaître
voici l'histoire mesdames et messieurs
du plus grand sosie de claude françois
qu'on n'est jamais rentré
non
que françoise ces mémos su que françoise
défi c'est de la poésie voilà ce que la
poésie c'est plutôt brassens non tu
m'emmerdes avec brassens toi un autre
post âge qui ferrait mes couilles avec
nouilles
j'ai pas lu ma couille au fond du ravin
ça y est le vrai bernard était de retour
enfin une nouvelle tournée bernard
frédéric et c'est vers là bas vous dire
que johnny hallyday au stade de france à
côté j'ai appelé non plus dans un mail
hier
quant à moi j'étais redevenu le coach de
bernard c'est vrai qu'à la
correctionnelle
un sosie et pékin il n'y avait aucune
personnalité
[Musique]
je te préviens bernard t'as pas intérêt
à déconner quatre d'entre vous d'avoir
l'immense privilège d'obtenir une bonne
note avec jean louis
puis
[Musique]
regardons web à banias
et
à
oh
fou qu'est ce que vous regardez quelques
dragons gül nombreuses tout assiette
[Applaudissements]
voilà peu dieu me yann moix et julie
depardieu jean claude rault et bien sûr
benoît tous bords alors si on revient de
parler avec cyril putman de la
dépendance à l'héroïne
mais là le héros il est vraiment
dépendant lui aussi c'est un film sur la
dépendance a ordonné de combrit c'est un
film sur la dépendance le héros son vice
c'est claude françois inna qui tombe
dans l'alcool il reste donc dans la
drogue comme dans le sexe d'autres
tombent dans le jeu lui tombe donc
l'autre france où la religion claude
françois la religion cloclo ouais c'est
ça si son scénario et il est adepte de
cette religion et voilà comme ça
voilà c'est exactement ça donc on ne
change pas de sujet en fait sauf que
c'est peut-être un petit peu moins
dangereux conceptual continuity voilà
oui alors d'abord vous avez eu l'idée
d'un film vous allez voir poelvoorde et
je vais faire un film là-dessus vous a
dit oui enfin tu es gentil vous ai fait
un roman vous êtes revenu voir sa durée
5 ans vous avez été d'un courage
exemplaire je me suis arrangée pour que
poelvoorde joue dans mon livre on va
dire que je vais injecter j'ai pu leur
disais mon roman avec ça serait sa verve
sa scansion que j'ai foutu du pouvoir
dans le bouquin et un jour je lui dis
tiens lis ça et imitant mais c'est moi
ça ouais et donc du coup il avait envie
de faire le film
s'ils avaient dit non vous n'auriez pas
fait le film non je serais rentré chez
moi continuer à écrire des livres sans
faire de toute façon à nice à corto
c'était pas mal non plus et souvent on
me dit est ce que c'est comment de faire
un film et je réponds je ne sais pas
faire un film moi je ne sais faire que
un film avec benoît poelvoorde
ouais j'en fais un meilleur à julie
depardieu dans un pool morel
obsessionnel et alors vous avez dit
aussi personnes doute ne peut le
réaliser à ma place c'est quand même
gonflé parce qu'elle vous enfilez plein
de thunes pour faire ce film alors vous
aviez jamais fait de film avant tout
qu'il voulait me filer encore plus et
une pour ne pas le faire donc maintenant
je vais je voulais pas céder parce que
on n'est jamais mieux trahi par soi même
même travers moi même car je ne suis pas
très fiable y compris vers moi même
c'est difficile le cadre l'image comme
ça c'est des choses que je faisais de la
bd avant d'écrire des bouquins ça m'a
vachement aider en fait ouais et puis
après j'ai regardé plein de films photos
et canon pour un premier film on peut
dire c'est visuellement assez réussie
quand même parce que c'est 50 boulot
j'ai commencé ce truc j'avais 29 ans là
j'aurai bientôt 36 kw à rien
c'est dur alors quant à julie depardieu
vous êtes rencontrés dans un bar en 1996
tous les deux et vous a dit je suis sûr
qu on travaillera ensemble
oui bon alors moi je j'ai rigolé sinon
je sais pas quelle était j depardieu une
blonde que je draguais aller non en fait
moi j'étais avec une copine qui était
brune qu'une carrière de plaire aussi la
télé donc la vie et non on était toutes
les deux et me dit j'ai un court métrage
là avec un hamster un truc très
hystérique j'ai bien compris je vais dit
ware écoute moi je ne suis pas triste
donc ça tombe bien donc il drague en
disant qu'ils étaient des cours ouais
quelques mystères des hamsters ce
littoral
oui et deux ans plus tard vous l'avez
fait ouais il a de la suite dans les
idées de garçons est est ce que ça fait
deux fois de suite là alors vous avez
dit vous en tous les cas dans tous les
films que je ferais julie oui c'est la
meilleure actrice de sa génération ac
davie a obtenu sa génération
oui il est incroyable parce que quand on
arrive sur un tournage la chose la moins
importante pour elle de la journée ces
moments où on tourne à l'ena mais
apparemment apparemment apparemment mais
sa façon se concentrer c'est d'en avoir
rien à [__] se fout d'être là bas
quand on regarde le truc quand on est
quand on regarde sur le plateau nu mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce truc mais ça
n'a jamais marché et quand on voit les
rushs ça marche on voit pas pourquoi ces
étonnantes vous dit julie moi j'ai pas
de propositions à faire sur un plateau
alors que tous les acteurs font des
propositions au real j'ai pas
d'imagination j'ai pas d'idée et j'ai
pas tiens voilà ce que c'est vrai au
niveau me demande je fais ce que je peux
et quand on me dit non ça va pas alors
effectivement je commence à me
me remuer un peu là où mais maintenant
je suis pas quelqu'un qui propose
beaucoup je propose moi c'est je trouve
que c'est déjà c'est déjà ça vous avez
un nom mais je sais vous avez ce côté là
c'est à dire quand vous étiez petit à
l'école mais raconter ça une fois quand
elle avait une copine protestante était
protestante une copine gill a été suivi
à zellik un peu oui
vous dites j'ai aucune admiration pour
les gens qui réussissent je trouve au
contraire beaucoup plus émouvant ce
qu'ils ratent ouais moi j'aime bien les
gens qui réussissent mais ça nous ça ne
me fait rien la réussite est la forme la
plus subtile de l'échec
ouais voilà j'aime kadhafi c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont copains si tu veux oui et
vous dit julie je me fous de plaire
l'enjeu c'est de pas trop me détester
oui enfin c'est pas plaire au plus grand
nombre tout ouais ouais c'est plaire à
une petite poignée à qui on a envie de
plaire ouais alors voulais pas
spécialement être une star a volé de
granby chance et ça va très bien mais
mon ambition c'est d'avoir des poules
oui mon projet 2004 celle annoncée le 4
le poulailler avec la volaille et j'en
aurai 3 je sais déjà les prénoms je sais
tout parce qu'on rousse et non c'est mon
projet voilà c'est un dribble pas
d'enfant voulait pas d'enfant bompas la
whey après peut-être peut-être n'en
parle et vous vous dites que vous
trouver ridicule et les les actrices qui
disent dans paris match ou dans gala
depuis que j'ai un enfant je vis un rêve
j'essaierai franchement si ça m'arrive
je suis fait un pari donc c'est un pari
idiot si vraiment si je
là je me fais dragon bien je ne veux pas
le dire ça parce que c'est une évidence
on le sait à quoi bon le dire et je
trouve ça ridicule de moi en tout cas je
ne le dirai pas même si c'est vrai c'est
pas tant par les matchs en tout cas
voilà
non je ne dirais pas non même si même si
c'est vrai mais ça m'arrache la gueule
je le dirai jamais alors contrairement à
votre père et votre frère vous dit
vraiment vous défier très très peu la
chronique
vous êtes d'une calme études absolument
exemplaire non mais c'est surtout que
non j'ai rien à dire enfin pas au plus
grand nombre en tout cas on va essayer
quand même à faire interner
quand on s'appelle depardieu
quand on s'appelle depardieu escompte
cdpa de chaque fois que l'on tombe de
vélo
non moi si je faisais une pub que je
serais pour le ménage parce que le seul
truc auquel je croise les produits
ménagers je pense à eux quand on
s'appelle depardieu est ce qu'on tient
bien l'alcool
ouais ouais cette famille oui parce
qu'on fait son vin soi même est ce que
quand on s'appelle depardieu on investit
son argent un peu n'importe comment non
pas quand on en a pas est-ce qu'on a
plus facilement des tableaux restaurant
non parce qu'on dit pas son nom
on a plus facilement des restaurants
peut-être est-ce qu'on a forcément un
drôle de rire quand on s'appelle
depardieu non regardez le mien est très
correct est ce que quand on s'appelle de
pardies on a parfois envie de porter un
autre nom oh oui oui mais là c'est un
peu tard maintenant j'aurais dû j'aurais
dû le faire à 12 ans comme on m'avait
proposé away qui avait proposé ce même
mon père voulait que tu t'appelles
comment on le sait pas elle n'avait pas
proposé mais il avait dira je vois que
ça te et une de par des f
non
[Musique]
et maintenant
voici gaston kelman
bonsoir bonsoir car on a deux noirs sur
le plateau et a dépassé le quota ici
c'est souvent le cas heureusement parce
que ça va pour les émissions y en a pas
alors ça va alors vous êtes ancien
directeur de l'observatoire urbain de la
ville d'evry vous publié chez max milo
un livre qui s'appelle sous le titre
génial je suis noir et je n'aime pas le
manioc voilà ce que vous êtes
bourguignon et ont préféré les escargots
les escargots le bon vin ouais les
poissons le fromage est assez bon le
charolais voilà plus tôt c'est vrai vous
avez raison vous dites qu'on a du mal en
france à comprendre qu'on puisse est
noire et bourguignons oui c'est vrai
c'est sa part être je ne sais pas
pourquoi un pourtant pu être blindé être
le breton oui aux sud africains
oui c'est vrai oui c'est vrai alors pour
vous l'existence précède l'essence comme
vous l'écrivez fort joliment et vous
dites je suis né bébé et noir je suis
devenu hommes et français
c'est mon choix parce que j'ai choisi
d'être c'est à dire que je dis je suis
né noire et africaine
gameiro n'est plus précisément parce que
c'est mes parents étaient de cette
origine et puis un jour pour mes enfants
j'ai fait le choix définitif d'être
français voilà vous dites qu à trois
types de racisme c'est assez intéressant
il ya un racisme vous traitez de
diabolique qui est tiré de la bible
c'est à dire que cham qui était le fils
de noé a vu son père nu malgré
l'interdiction
il est devenu tout noir ça que dans la
bible en fait la négritude la couleur
noire c'était une sanction c'est une
malédiction tout à fait vrai chameau
réel vu effectivement la nullité de son
père noël et son père lui a dit tu seras
maudit et tu sers à l'esclave d'été
frais lui aurait dit en tout cas c'est
ce qui a permis par exemple
d'accréditer l'esclavagé la traite des
noirs parce que c'était écrit donc non
parce qu'en ce moment tout le monde nous
parle du corps en disant que c'est
terrible mais mais la bible aussi alors
il faut arrêter que ce bouquin non non
non mais si c'est un bon gars très jazzy
des interprétations hasardeuses s'appuie
tout ça enfin bon c'est pas tout dire du
mal du camp mais j'ai des conneries dans
l'abîmé alors premier racisme diabolique
c'est celui là aussi franchement qui ne
se passe que ça ne comble pas de
fioritures je ne t'aime pas parce que tu
es différent de moi tu seras jamais égal
à moi c'est clair c'est net c'est
l'apartheid c'est le couscous klahn
l'éclair il ne fait peur à personne
parce que tu peux pas se cacher premier
le deuxième c'est ce que vous appelez le
racisme angélique alors c'est le
paternalisme c'est à dire c'est le
sanglot de l'homme blanc quoi dire on
l'a tellement fait de mal à ces pauvres
gens qu'ils sont bien sympas faut les
aider enfin si vous souffrez un doigt
plus souffrir voilà on traite les noirs
comme des handicapés dans ce cas là
et le troisième c'est le racisme
anthropologique c'est-à-dire l'on
connaît car ils ont un cerveau -
développer ma chance et toutes les
théories nazies d'une certaine voilà
l'essentialisation ou moi je l'aurais le
rythme dans le sens où j'essaierai
danseurs de bambou l'intérêt majeur de
manioc voilà qu'est ce qu'on pense pas
si de ça je pense qu'il a raison sur
plein de sujets de sur plein de points
ouais bon le titre bon moi je mange
manière que ça va en même temps je suis
bon échange je le rejoins peu et je suis
quand même fier et je pense que on doit
prouver qu'avec nos cultures
malgré tout on est capable de faire
aussi bien que n'importe qui dans le
monde
oui parce que vous dites un truc est
juste gaston vous dit
finalement quand on parle de sarkozy
personne se souvient qu'il en hongrois
quand enfin d'origine hongroise quand on
parle de devedjian personnes nous parle
de l'arménie alors qu'un noir il sera
toujours relié à l'afrique même si elle
habite depuis des années des années et
c'est pour cela que je veux que s'arrête
l'antillais qui est français depuis des
siècles et les continents antillais
quand il est noir et européens
on nous demande parfois de parfois la
france et les antilles on lui dit si
souvent il ya des gens qui sont de saint
louis du sénégal des antilles fin qu'ils
sont des noirs français depuis des
siècles et des siècles ils sont moins
considéré français que le que dmc le rsa
c'est tout à fait juste
alors dans le cinéma français par
exemple où dit on en est au point on
était aux états unis à 50 ans à l'époque
de sidney poitier avec devine qui vient
dîner qu'un film absolument génial là
dessus et c'est vrai que en france bon
il ya un petit peu des noirs comme ça
dans les films et tout mais quand même
on en est on en est très loin de ce qui
se passe j'ai sur nos jours iata il n'y
a pas de noirs libérateur comme west
nile breeze ans n'a comme denzel
washington comme tous les autres qui ont
leur place aujourd'hui et je pense que
c'est là que la positive affirmative
action qu'on traduit à tort par
discrimination positive parce que je
vois pas d'où vient la destination là je
peux dire une action volontariste c'est
là qu'on voit ses effets qu'ils ont eue
qui ont été calmes et fort dans le
cinéma américain par exemple c'est clair
que c'est cette volonté parce que les
noirs et plaisantait désormais 10 % des
américains parce qu'il représentait une
force mon enfance et 10% aussi en france
aussi 10% c'est fou alors qu'il n'y a
aucun film français ou vous avez un
droit requis problème pas spécifiquement
français puisqu'on on a un modèle pour
réfléchir à ça c'est le brésil le brésil
est un pays plus mais qui sait du monde
il dans l'es9 et la brésilienne
les noirs jouent encore le rôle des
majordomes dire que le brésil est un des
pays les plus racistes que je connais
c'est pourtant tout le monde est métisse
mais il ya des noirs plus des noirs moi
il ya comme un racisme entre les noirs
plus les noirs - sinon oui tu as raison
mais c'est vrai que dans l'inconscient
collectif ya toujours le mythe de
l'éboueur ouais c'est à dire le lenoir a
toujours une fonction subalterne eux
mêmes après tout toutes ces années dans
une histoire extraordinaire si sur
l'hôpital de bamako la cour a compté
dans votre book est arrivé oui cette
série noire qui a dans la l'hôpital et
termine
il était en vacances il est tombé malade
il va à l'hôpital et puis un officiel
français qui passent par là et ils se
croient obligés de lui par les petits
[__] toi mon ami tu racontes ardente
remplace gagner petit sou doit faire
quoi en france et je suis professeur à
la sorbonne monsieur c'est pour faire
des littératures
et avec les lectrices torts bouquin
c'est l'histoire de fida kelman ses mots
non c'est quelle manne dont ma fille
seyfried a qu'au final ça fait
extrêmement alsacien ou allemands plus
tôt donc elles demandent des stages un
troisième et d'immersion à l'emploi et
on nous avait pas de problème parce
qu'elle est là l'accent franciliens moi
j'ai laxenburg mignon comme vous pouvez
le constater la l'accent franciliens et
elle passe inaperçue donc kelman frida
stage parfait tu arrives pas si elle
arrive et puis je suis venu pour le
stage je suis désolé ma demande et les
prix et ma fille leur demande par qui si
vous le donne en mille
frida calme hanafuda kelman il été pris
alors c'est très intéressant dans votre
bouquin si vous distinguer les garçons
et les filles si el kala blackitude ça
c'est les mecs pour vous en tous les cas
c'est un peu un repli sur soi même on
est black and black and clyde un peu en
repli et puis au contraire les filles
qui sont beaucoup plus ouverte sur le
mélange à plessala maronite et alors
avec évidemment le danger de michael
jackson isation le côté caméléon quoi
c'est à dire on l'ouverture et c'est
vrai ça c'est extraordinaire je crois
que beaucoup de parents comme moi ont eu
cette anecdote là où un jour l'api 32
les collègues il pas parce que je suis
noir
bon parfois c'est difficile de lui dire
qu'elle est autre chose
oui oui oui moi tu es noir najima wrong
way
et puis après on se pose la question de
pourquoi ma fille je veux marron rien
faire quand on est dans la problématique
entrée dans le métier on se met à
réfléchir j'ai réfléchi c'est du coup
pourquoi ce que les marrons et les
garçons pourquoi est-ce qu'ils sont
blacks parce que les garçons qui sont
aussi dans cette logique de ce centre gt
est tout de suite ils se disent parce
que le garçon comme un porteur d'un
patrimoine et c'est nul je suis là et là
je n'ai pas du tout à transiger
je vais me battre sauf que dans ce
combat il perdra alors vous parlez ce
que des édulcorants linguistique voilà
justement ce que on sera obligé toujours
de pluie de la fuite en avant
effectivement nous étions noir et avec
l'esclavagé après l'esclavagé était plus
tellement bien de dire noir désir et
benêt gros on est devenu noir et puis
après certaines personnes avec la
colonisation récupérer le mot noir
l'aura du négatif on a des jeunes hommes
de couleur quelle horreur et puis j
apprends homme de couleur à face
aujourd'hui
duceppe selon elle en est devenue black
et benoît d'ailleurs oui ça c'est plus
court et parce qu'effectivement c'est
très bien que quand on quand on emprunte
dans une autre langue
ça passe plus facilement un homme cette
fois pour le all black and cloud à je
suis noir je suis fier qui a été quand
même le quand même le slogan de des
noirs aux états unis depuis les années
70 parce que vous dites non moi je suis
noir et je n'en suis pas spécialement
fiers d'abord parce que la situation
actuelle dans les pays d'afrique donc
déjà qui vous remplace spécialement
fiers et puis vous dites aussi cette
chose terrible c'est que c'est des noirs
du temps esclavage qui ont vendu des
noirs c'est un fait
je n'imagine pas qu'on dise ce fait là
ça évidemment cela ne cautionne à rien
le fait que le pays des droits de
l'homme que le pays de 2 2 le pays des
philosophes que le pays de la sagesse
ffs a aussi bon les autres ont fait
pareil mais c'est un fait aujourd'hui
qu'il ya eu ce malaise là qu'on devrait
va qu'une aussi et de dire oui c'est
vrai on a fait ça c'était pas bien on a
pas de fierté à avoir une couleur de
peau qu'on a kiss comme ça au hasard
d'une naissance je sais pas si on est
fier d'être blanc fière d'être une
journée fier d'être le rouge
c'est pas pour moi la fierté c'est
l'acquisition ce qu'on a à qui se fier
d'être un musicien je suis fier d'être
leur un diplôme et je suis fier d'être
un artiste je suis fier de sa première
chose
deuxième chose la fierté effectivement
quand elle sort de notre bouche c'est
comme si on disait je suis fier parce
que vous croyez que je ne le suis pas
oui parce que les points que j'ai honte
alors je vais crier ma fierté est
justement cette démarche de crier sa
fierté
c'est en quelque sorte reconnaître que
vous ne la méritais riez peut-être pas
les anglophones ont un discours
différent et et wole soyinka qui a été
le plus nobel de littérature disait le
tigre ne plie pas sa tigritude que la
clape sa foi et la boit et inversement
on devrait pouvoir traiter un noir de
sale connard so lu ment problème mais je
le fais pas parce qu'on a peur de la
peur de l'autre d'accès et la définition
de l'absence de racisme c'est de pouvoir
dire un noir gros con mais c'est
toujours bien noir gros con on ne sera
plus raciste c'est le racisme exact
c'est le racisme à schilick dont je
parlais surtout noria leur langage et
des centres la fierté c'est aussi
souvent quand on regarde à la télé qu'on
voit pas qu'on voit que les noirs sont
pas souvent représentés quand on regarde
au niveau politique et pas beaucoup de
monde dans la politique et leur cas des
noirs français depuis bien longtemps
donc le côté fier c'est aussi de dire
bon c'est pas grave on ne reconnaît pas
mais nous on va se débrouiller pour moi
c'est de laisser ces communautés a dit
fier parce qu'on est tout pour moi je
suis fier d'être blanc d'être chinois
d'être noir d'être d'être fiers déjà
deux de ce que la vie nous a donné et
d'avancer avec de prouver que c'est pas
parce que tu as telle couleur que t'es
con moi c'est comme ça que je vois
justement je suis fier de participer à
l'évolution de la face au développement
de la france mais je suis pas fier parce
que je suis noir et je suis tout
simplement fier parce que je suis un
citoyen qui participe à quelque chose là
je mérite cette fierté et je dis aussi
en troisième position que c'est vrai que
effectivement par rapport quand on voit
l'afrique aujourd'hui quand on atteint
président dira
l'afrique l'afrique 1 650 millions
d'habitants sans la france dix fois
moins c'est comme un véhicule sans
moteur je vous assure qu'après et aussi
je vous les voyez venir à paris vient de
rendre hommage à leur seigneur et maître
franchement moi personnellement je suis
pas fils et moi je dis ça ne devrait pas
arriver
christophe comme j'ai lu dans le livre
un moment donné il le dit très justement
il ya quand même une vaste hypocrisie
derrière tout ça où on dit que par la
france est un pays multiculturel
alors qu'on devrait dire un pays
multiracial oui et on se voile un peu la
face quand même en disant
multiculturelle qu'est ce que ça veut
dire eh oui c'est vrai c'est juste je
donne l'exemple par exemple du couscous
qui était arabe ya 15 ans aujourd'hui à
l'époque qu'est ce qui faisait la
publicité du couscous était couscous
garbit c'est bon comme là bas dit il je
suis d'accord c'est simplement la
ressent le turban tous étaient arabes
aujourd'hui c'est des bigoudens qui font
la publicité sur le couscous est devenu
phrase aussi bien la publicité
tout à fait et gaston alors dernière
chose la taille du sexe en c'est très
décevant quand on lit votre bouquin on
s'aperçoit qu'on prétend avoir une
petite guitare d'un seul coup c'est
voilà le démolit tout va là c'est vrai
beaucoup de blanc ouais ouais lequel que
ça va s'arracher de ce côté-là non mais
je le rappelle par exemple journalistes
jeudi noir qui faisait toujours je te
tiens je suis content que tenir on avait
une seule chose toute la rage est
maintenant on a plus aucun élément de
fierté
non bon c'est la petite boutade pour
parce que le livre j'ai pour les 5 à 7
ans vous avez une petite [__] vous
voulez voir c'est vrai c'est énorme et
ça les gens sont persuadés de ça ça fait
partie des clichés qui les clichés rue
louis et c'est là aussi viennent un peu
des états unis parce que pendant
l'esclavagé des noirs étaient un peu et
allons laisser les femmes qui étaient un
peu esclave exemple venait de plantation
implantations pour les essais mines et
comme les cheveux coiffés comme et le
cheval il se débrouille bien donc land
état et allons lui aussi forcément
devaient quand il y avait 50 ans dans
une antichambre ça devenait une forêt de
llança aller dans tous les sens le
pouvoir arrête tu m'excite l'agacement
voilà gaston kelman gaston kelman je
suis noir et je n'aime fans
or ces deux éditions max milo mais les
messieurs mais maintenant on passe au
blind test
et aux platines j'accueille mois juin
philippe cartier
nancy retour
alors ça fuse de rentrer à la maison
tiens d'ailleurs à mes yeux ça va mieux
et ouais j'suis pas venu tout seul un ah
bon l'annoncé inspirait les deux
brésiliennes de l'autre jour les deux
ouais
les trois noms ici
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
les cadeaux bravo bravo
oh
attention
à
mavuba
ce que je voudrais bien fait vibrer il
faut bien préciser pour nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est que ce sont de
vraies filles voilà est-ce que tu es
prêt pour le spécial brésil
vous connaissez le principe monsieur
lévesque oui est ce qu a prévu sept
genre de mec à faire des récriminations
à le principe est simple je veux
l'interprète
moi mon but c'est tricher ça c'est clair
attention aux défis sont au courant
assez il ya soufflage via bernage des
habillages rap déshabillage bah oui
[Applaudissements]
carnaval de rio qui en avalent rehab la
chine
bon alors on y va je veux l'interprète
attention on venait de parler de racisme
mais là et on n'a pas envie d'être assis
en pas du tout du tout la wii alors je
ride il
il sera soustrait attention aux philippe
numéro du royaume à l'eau
6e
montella
un point pour l'équipe de laurent baffie
oui on l'a même quand je savais même pas
que ça commençait à 6,5 à commencer par
cissé commence
l'appareil bruit venu le monde arabe et
la taurine à temps aux instants mais
lindsay faire un point pour l'équipe de
laurent baffie est géré au point pour
l'équipe de julie depardieu c'est ça et
je rappelle que le vainqueur repart avec
une d'entre elles
al et moi sur la cheminée
les deux offres qui respecte et remercie
fini attention numéro 2
[Musique]
oui
en tout cas
annie cordy annie cordy les bienvenus
j'ai la tune a dit avant laurent
wauquiez replay ripper ah oui
alors si pour le petit bébé sarkozy
votre corps
à l'école et annie cordy
non
nous aussi
nous avons la preuve c'est bien lui qui
avait répondu juste vendre leur âme
les vignerons batterie et zéro point
pour l'équipe de julie depardieu choisi
prix
[Musique]
bravo
la vérification serti attention pas
amara
bibi battant philipp belle excuse moi
mais là je voudrais quand même on fait
de la télévision sur service public et
qu'on soit à peu près 6 pour nos amis
téléspectateurs quel est le prénom de
cette jeune fille carla
bonsoir carla et la jeune fille manuela
et manuela bonsoir lohan mais aussi très
bien bien allons-y fini
[Musique]
il ya du souffle ayari oui à perdre âge
un peu ils ont pas il interprètera c'est
vrai by db non non comme un peuple le
poids va la jouer à à dampmart à aa
c'est bien
oui bien sûr plage et six mois le poids
va là et quand il ya soufflage là le
mauvais sidaction
c'est connu secours
non je vous demande de ne pas souffler
puisque vous avez une fois l'équipe
adverse donc c'est pas bien donc
effectivement c'était alain chabat géant
dormant carioca et voilà allons-y
philippe filles rosa fugain sisteronne
âmes qui sont partis pour la raho
[Musique]
non moi je vais dire j'ai demandé une
prime de risque pour faire cette
émission attention philippe
la vie et à kara qui t'arrive
ça va
m
[Musique]
ses amis
n'est ce pas
à attention philippe vassili bost
fastidieux
et
c'est vrai
ouais
regarde moi oui la trouver ian martin
mais ça
oui vu sérieusement way où tu as trouvé
tes amis là alors on écoute à elle et
les dentistes elle fait elle vient de
finir ses études on connaît en france
pour voir ses parents non c'est vrai
talent c'est vrai en plus mal aux dents
mais aussi le premier truc je lui ai dit
quand je les ai vus
elle est ici et c'est une jeune
étudiante qui s'appelle carla étudiante
ici aussi on a arrêté nos études on est
con ben voila tu continue philippe
lazare
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
dj benji ouais enfin maman cette
révélation
oh
bon alors par équipes c'est indéniable
c'est l'équipe de long mafiques a gagné
la mémoire
fait la tête pourquoi parce qu'elle a
perdu
on oblige idée mais c'est gagner sinon
vous aurez traité de raciste
[Applaudissements]
c'est la foire aux bonnes places de
confusion n'est pas noir mais tu
voudrais être noir comme nino ferrer
comme nino ferrer qu'on regrette chaque
jour un peu plus attention alors
maintenant vous avez compris le principe
le par équipes c'est fini on passe sous
chacun pour sa gueule
pourquoi parce que la vie est juste et
bien la ville juste que maintenant c'est
chacun pour sa gueule quand vous allez
là il ya plus d'équipés attention
philippe base il joue
[Musique]
quantic une porte
il a trouvé un way est blanchi
la mamie
il n'y avait pas
ottawa tant que pères blancs
bastien wibaux témoin veut commencer à
vivre quand tu es chez toi c'est moi le
suivant en toute modestie assez la même
époque le podium celle à chanter la
chanter en français par lui lolo igor
boyer nord
non la croisière s'amuse
et moi le show girl my name is law ouais
ouais
rony brauman
pac man tilt ici
rien
[Musique]
pas
bien donc la selo ma fille qui a
remporté le banco et le super-banco bien
lors encaissant pense c'était tout le
monde en parle
c'était tout le monde en parle je pense
que c'est des mecs bien sûr merci
philippe garcia s'était tout le monde en
parle avec leurs envies
bernard tapie natacha malle agnès soral
pascal robert beynat pour un beau [__]
a d'abord tâté regarde paris voilà
véronique jannot pour les monologues du
vagin rigueur ni janot nicole croisille
et c'est lawson au petit théâtre de
paris rue blanche aussi c'est à 19
heures à l'occasion du bi des bobos
mondiale contre la violence envers les
femmes
soirée exceptionnelle le 8 mars à 20h15
au théâtre de paris
les bénéfices sont reversés à plusieurs
associations dont ni [__] ni soumises
bernard kouchner les quais
et c'est chez grasset olivia commerciaux
avec l'album s'appelle andy booth et les
morceaux dans la nuit s'appelle roméo et
juliette lewis
elle est dans blueberry de jan kounen
avec
sans cassel avec michael madsen charles
ans février et 11 février d'où mairie
christophe alévêque et je tapais
lévesque et son troupeau
tous les premiers lundis du mois à la
scène ont pris le taillandier à paris
dans leurs anciennes
aussi bien chez nc dvd 30 ans croteau
l'album this et sort le 22 mars et le
morceau qu'ont entendu s'appelle reviens
dans ma vie je n'ai pas de grossir
s'évanouissent au chicago avec stéphane
rousseau allocation de l'olivier avec
véronic dicaire et ses citoyens
si notre avis
[Musique]
je surveillais chicago shearim potable
première pression à froid chez robert
laffont
yann moix et julie depardieu frappe au
feutre noir avec julie depardieu benoît
poelvoorde jean polo ça sent le 11
février
gaston kelman mercedes dont je suis noir
et je n'aime pas le manioc séché max
milo
merci vite parti pourtant pleine tête
mais je rappelle la forme
reporters sans frontières achetez le
c'est pour aider des journalistes
emprisonnés
voilà c'est tuer tout le monde en parle
rendez vous la semaine prochaine
simard
[Musique]
gernez
hu
charest
à
je n'ai
[Musique]
mais si mais si
ben achour
ces machines
à
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus